Hey everybody.
Welcome to the Podcast.
My guest today is Bryan Fogel.
Bryan is a filmmaker.
He won an Oscar for his documentary "Icarus",
which if you have not seen it, you must.
He was a guest on the podcast a couple of years ago.
Bryan is back with a new film, it's called "The Dissident",
which is about the murder of journalist Jamal Khashoggi.
It's extraordinary.
This conversation is utterly compelling,
I think you guys are gonna really dig it.
So hit that subscribe button and please enjoy
my conversation with filmmaker, Bryan Fogel.
My name is Hatice Cengiz.
I am addressing you as a victim.
A title forced on me after the brutal murder of my Jamal.
Jamal Khashoggi, prominent Saudi journalist
and Washington Post columnist has gone missing
after visiting his country's consulate in Istanbul.
He was last seen entering
Saudi Arabia's consulate, taking paperwork
to marry his fiancee.
His fiancee saw him go in at 1:00 PM
and was still waiting for him at 1:00 AM.
Could you tell me what happened to Khashoggi?
Saudi Arabia, now suddenly there's admitting
that Khashoggi did die inside that building.
The government treated me as if I hurt the King.
We knew that they would try to sweep the whole thing
under the rug.
Is it true that Turkish intelligence
obtained audio recordings to Khashoggi's murder?
I know why Jamal was killed.
It's because of me.
He saved some particularly damning piece of the puzzle
like Saudi body double.
Jamal felt the whole country was against him.
This is another truth.
I said the best solution
is creating our own army.
The King firmly denies any knowledge of it.
It could have been rogue killers, who knows?
I just received this, "Be careful,
move from city to another one and there's a team
is going to kill you soon."
It's anonymous.
He has to be killed in a way that will send a message
to everyone else, because the if you kill Jamal
with his papers, who else you cannot kill?
You can kill everyone.
I (indistinct) Jamal.
Once you starts working with us, you're not just
a journalist, you're a dissident.
What do you know about the bees?
And a lot has happened in the last couple of years
in your life.
It's been a crazy trajectory for you.
Yeah, it's been an interesting a few years.
That's for sure.
What was it like when you won the Oscar
and you were up on that stage?
I mean, that has to be one of the most surreal experiences
you can imagine.
It was March of 2018, and it was surreal,
and what was interesting is leading up to that,
the months up to it, "Icarus" released on Netflix
in August of 2017.
And the Academy awards was August, September,
October, November, December, January, February, March,
eight months later, seven months later.
And Netflix had put a lot of energy behind essentially
this award campaign and I had never went through
anything like this before, and so it was seven months
of every day of my life, you're waking up
and here's your schedule for the day, here's your press,
here's where you're going, here's your screenings,
here's where you're going, and it was intense.
And so, the lead up into that was months and months
and months and months and months of this kind of campaign.
And so I came into the...
But from the time we get nominated to actually going
to the Academy Awards and there I'm there sitting there,
I mean, it felt like there was an elephant on me.
I wasn't, at that point, having fun,
'cause it was amazing, and at the same time,
the pressure because there was show much feeling for me
at stake and Netflix and my partners and everything
had put so much into it.
And so we were all there, kind of like on pins and needles,
and luckily they called the award for Best Documentary,
I think it was like the third or fourth award of the night.
Yeah, it was early in the night.
Which was really, really good because you're sitting there
and they called "Icarus", and I just remember
at that moment, I had essentially had left my body.
I mean, it was just you were walking up on the stage there
and there's this person, that person,
everybody in the entertainment-
That front row just looking up at you.
You've ever admired and you're sitting there going like,
wow, I'm on the stage at the Academy Awards
with a Oscar in my head, and they handed me that Oscar
and it's...
I don't know how many pounds it is, it's like 12, 13 pounds
or 10, I mean, it's heavy.
I was like, whoa, I was like (laughs).
And yeah, it was completely surreal, and an actor
won the statue.
You're led into this labyrinth underneath the Kodak Theater
and you come out of the labyrinth about an hour later
because they walk you through all these stations of photos
and then a booth like, "What was it like to win the Oscar?"
and all these kind of surreal things,
and you emerge about an hour later,
and as I kind of emerge out of the cavern
about an hour later, right where the backstage is,
is, can't remember if it is a Joel or Ethan Coen
who's married to Frances McDormand.
I think it's Joel.
Joel.
So, Joel is there and Frances won the Academy Award
that night for Best Actress, and he goes to me,
"Enjoy this."
And he goes, yeah, he's like,
"Because it's like you never...
He's like, "The odds are, this is never gonna happen again."
(Bryan and Rich laugh)
And he also goes, he's like, and he tells me
this crazy funny story about Sylvester Stallone
that I won't repeat, and I just went on like,
this is so surreal.
I just won an Academy Award, I really should remember
if it's Joel or Ethan Coen, talking to me like,
they're my favorite filmmakers of all time,
and, it was quite a night.
It's pretty cool.
And my parents were there too.
Oh, that's nice.
Yeah.
The campaigning that goes into the Oscar season is bananas.
There's so much at stake for these companies.
It is bananas and what's interesting is, in COVID now,
where it's so radically different because-
Right, you can't press the flesh
and go to all these lunches and all that kind of stuff.
And all these screenings where with "Icarus"
you had, I don't even know, 30, 40 screenings,
were small screenings and you're meeting people
and it was wonderful because I got to meet so many people,
so many people that I looked up to or filmmakers
or documentarians or you name it,
and so COVID has really, really changed that,
but it's really intense because there's a playbook,
you've got your talking points
and you've got the do's and the don'ts
and what you're gonna say and what you shouldn't say
and how to answer a question and everything was so,
it was intense.
Yes.
It was intense and the press I was doing,
you then kind of like you'd go do an interview,
and then after the interview, it was like,
"Okay, that was really good, but maybe change
the next time you answered the question, do this."
(Bryan and Rich laugh)
Well, thinking back to when you did the Podcast,
I mean, you're definitely lighter in your shoes today
than you were on that day.
We had just met, so we didn't know each other really,
but there was a little bit more of a seriousness
and maybe a sense that you were shouldering
that kind of heavy responsibility at the time.
Yeah.
I just thought it was interesting.
I remember going through that so well,
because I was enjoying it and the same time,
I actually was I was so stressed out because each one
of these events, you do these events and then it was like,
okay, was that okay?
And then I'd replay it in my mind and go,
did I answer a question the right way,
or did I say something that was wrong?
Your publicist didn't call you and chew you out
for, listen, if you're going on podcasts though
and you're talking for a couple hours.
I mean, the entire lead up to the Oscars
and just that whole season, I mean, it was so intense
and we had been nominated for a BAFTA.
And so I'd been at the BAFTAs like two weeks before that,
and we didn't win.
And so you come out of the BAFTAs and here you're feeling
completely defeated, but you've got the Oscar nomination
and everybody at the time was going,
"Well, don't worry about that, you still got the Oscars."
But I mean, it was an incredible experience,
but I can't tell you that I was having fun
during that period.
And part of it really had to do with
what "Icarus" was about, and that here
as this whole award season is going, and Grigory Rodchenkov,
the whistleblower to this day is living in hiding,
in protective custody, is isolated.
And so what was weighing on me also, was that,
okay, here I am having these experiences
and I'm being celebrated and the guy who-
Without him, that would not have been possible, yeah.
This wouldn't have been possible without his evidence,
without that story, none of this would be happening,
is basically living an isolation in an undisclosed location,
under security, under the threat of his life,
and, here I am on this completely different trajectory now.
And that really weighed on me, still weighs on me.
Yeah, I mean, my first question, I mean,
we're here to talk about "The Dissident", your new film,
but we can't get into that without hearing
a little bit about how Grigory is doing.
Are you in communication with him?
What's the latest?
I know he put this book out recently.
He put his book out, which is his memoir of his life.
And actually, I can say this now because, by the time
you hear this, it'll be known, it just won
the William Hill Sports Book of the Year,
which is a very prestigious prize in the UK.
So he just won the basically British Sports Book
of the Year award for the book, and yet the book
still doesn't have a US publisher, which is bizarre.
Yeah, I noticed that.
He'd self-published it?
No, it was published by Penguin Random House in the UK
and then we couldn't get a US deal for it.
I was involved just as no financial stake,
nothing just trying to help facilitate,
but the book's pretty amazing,
and so that came out a couple months ago,
but I'm not able to communicate directly with him.
I don't have his phone number, I don't know where he lives.
I don't wanna know where he lives, but we've been able
to stay in touch through his lawyers, and he's doing okay
but he hasn't seen his family since he escaped Russia,
which was in November of 2015.
He went into protective custody in July of 2016,
so four years in, four and a half years in
of essentially this guy living in isolation, in protection.
And what's interesting is that the story
has continued to evolve.
When "Icarus" released in August, 2017,
Russia was still going to the Olympics.
Five months later, basically because of what
that film's impact had been on the world at that point,
and the global distribution that Netflix has,
the Olympics, the IOC essentially had to do something.
So even though at that point, the story had been
in the press and the media, it's very different.
Okay, you see something on CNN or read something
in the New York Times versus now
you're emotionally connecting to a character
and you're seeing this in a film and you're realizing
the extent of his fraud and kind of how bad it really was.
the IOC decides to ban Russia
from the PyeongChang Olympic games in 2018,
and in the decision of the ban, even though the ban
was largely ceremonial, because Russia was then able
to still compete, but not under their own flag,
and the athletes were competing
as Olympic athletes from Russia,
they cited "Icarus" in the reasoned decision.
Wow.
And so that was the Olympics, I think were February, 2018,
and then at the time there was the, still WADA,
The World Anti-Doping Agency had put together this roadmap,
which was okay, here's the three things that Russia
needs to do to get reinstated into world sport.
And one of them was that they were supposed to provide
the LIMS data, which is the Laboratory Management System
data of everything they had been up to over the past decade,
kind of thing, like, "Okay, we know you cheated,
but you guys gotta come clean and you need to provide
this data because they had believed that
what was in this database was a ton
of other doping violations and frauds
that the urine swapping and the opening the bottles
and all the other kind of stuff.
And Rodchenkov Grigory had said, "Yeah,
there are tons and tons of cases in here that
that I entered into the system as negative,
that were actually positive."
Right?
"And here's what we did."
So that was the first thing they had to turnover.
The second thing for Russia's reinstatement
was that they were going to accept
the Richard McLaren Report, which was after
we brought the story public to the New York Times
in May of 2016.
Richard McLaren, the investigator who was brought in
by the World Anti-Doping agency to investigate Rodchenkov's
allegations, authors this report over the next year.
And the report, basically, goes down a rabbit hole
of insanity of how big this fraud was.
And it was all backed up through scientific data
and researchers and forensic evidence, et cetera,
and that Russia had to accept the McLaren Report
as fact, right?
And the third thing, was that there was gonna be
a massive reform to the anti-doping system
and that there'd be all this oversight
and all this stuff, right?
So they had set this as the three things
that Russia had to do to get back in.
And here we are, basically, two years later,
it's now actually, at like the beginning
of this year, right?
And Russia still hadn't accepted the McLaren Report,
still hadn't returned over the LIMS data,
but WADA re-instates him into competition,
basically just going back on their own word
that this had to happen.
The point of this story is that they finally turn over
this LIMS data, and I don't wanna mess up the date,
but this is sometime around a year ago,
they finally turned over the LIMS data
and in turning over the database, Russia had went in
before they turned it over to WADA and it manipulated
the entire database, but WADA already had
the real database that Rodchenkov had turned over to them,
of what it was supposed to be, right?
Right.
And now the one that Russia turns over is basically
been completely manipulated to erase all these positives,
to erase Rodchenkov's evidence, but not only that,
they had made notes into the database
pretending to be Grigory writing these notes,
to basically blame the entire scandal, again, on Rodchenkov,
that this was all a big conspiracy that Rodchenkov
had acted as a sole practitioner, KGB, FSB had nothing
to do with this, the state wasn't involved
and WADA goes, what is this, guys?
Are you kidding me?
And so they basically re-banned Russia
for another four years, and this is where it stands
right now today.
That's the current state.
Russia is still suspended from international competition.
Had the Olympics happened this last summer in 2020,
the recommendation was Russia was gonna be banned
from the summer Olympic games.
We don't know if that was gonna happen
'cause they were fighting that
in the Court of Arbitration for sport.
Right, that was unresolved.
And the IOC had made the decision,
so where this stands right now, here we are,
essentially, four years old, but two years on
from the winter games is, Russia has continued
to deny they're re-banned, and again, as of right now,
they're not going to the summer games,
if they were to happen in 2021 and Rodchenkov,
not only is he persona non grata,
if you pull all the Russian media, I mean,
this guy is essentially the arch enemy of arch enemies
in the overall history of the Russian Federation.
I mean,-
And as long as Putin is in power,
that will remain to be the case.
I mean, we've heard reports through his attorneys
from CIA intelligence, is that he is either number one
or number two on Russia's kill list.
About a year ago, if you remember,
there were nine Russian agents that were kicked
out of the country, that actually Trump administration
had discovered these nine basically secret agents
that were working in the country and they kicked them out.
They were supposed to be...
I'm gonna botch this story, but they apparently
they were Russian diplomats and whatever,
but then the State Department determined they were spies.
Right, so they were actually working on behalf of the FSB
to come and sort of route out Rodchenkov here in the States.
Apparently, three of those agents of these nine
that were expelled from the United States
were here hunting Rodchenkov, and there's been reports
on Bellingcat, which is this investigative
circle of journalists, that even when he was supposed
to appear, Russia thought that he was gonna appear
at these hearings in Luzon, Switzerland,
which of course, he appeared via like Skype or Zoom,
but they thought that he was going to be there in-person,
and there were agents that were in Luzon,
essentially waiting for him.
There's all sorts of evidence that's been uncovered
in the last few years of...
They're hunting this guy.
That's so dark.
And you look at Navalny, the guy who was poisoned
in Germany, whenever that was five, six months ago,
with Novichok and Skripal, which was March of 2018,
in the UK.
They poisoned him and his daughter, Litvinenko
and then all these other mysterious murders
and some that have, been looked at as hangings
and suicides and this, that, and the other,
it is clear that Russia doesn't forget.
Right, wow.
So-
How has this impacted you personally?
Are you on the receiving end of some of these threats,
veiled or otherwise?
Gratefully I've never received a threat
and I've never received an email threat
or a text message threat or social media threat,
and the way that I've always looked at it myself is that,
why would you shoot the messenger?
And I think, Russia, and you even hear Putin
when they asked him about the Skripal poisonings,
and you can go look at interviews and they go,
"Well, did you do this?"
And he goes, "No, I didn't do this, but treason
is the highest crime and it should be punished.", so-
Yeah.
Basically, I didn't do this, but, if somebody did do this,
this was warranted because treason is the highest crime.
And I can't speak for how Russia, but if you look
at even the poisoning of Alexander Litvinenko in 2006,
or Skripal, right?
These were acts of treason and Grigory is viewed
as a traitor, a defector, and I would imagine
that even Garry Kasparov is on that list,
as a defector and a guy who was the pride of Russia,
who's now come very, very public
in the past several years against Putin.
But, hopefully, I'm okay, and needless to say,
I'm not planning any trips to Moscow any time soon.
Yeah, and now probably not to Saudi Arabia.
Yeah, definitely not Saudi Arabia.
What's happening now?
Definitely not.
Yeah, and it's a perfect segue into the new film,
because that's essentially an overlapping narrative
with what you explore in the murder of Khashoggi,
this idea of power unchecked, where whether it's Putin
or MBS, they kinda want you to know it's them
without saying it's them, because they wanna put the message
out that they mean business.
But perhaps there's also an under appreciation
for the kind of global response and reaction to these events
where there's a growing intolerance for this kind of thing.
I suspect that MBS didn't anticipate the level of outrage
that he kind of invited upon himself
as a result of all of this.
Well, I don't think he expected that there was going
to be a bug, a listening device in the Saudi consulate,
in Istanbul that was going to prove beyond
a shadow of a doubt, I mean, just flat out
what had happened in that consulate.
And so the Khashoggi murder was just horrifying,
but I don't think that MBS, when you go into the details
of a case, it was so stupidly planned and it was so brazen
and outrageous, but obviously, they couldn't have imagined
that there was a listening device in the consulate,
in the room that they decided to murder him in,
and that's a whole story about that.
Right, I mean, that was a big question,
and before we get too deep into this,
we should probably just synopsize the film a little bit
for people that aren't familiar, but what wasn't
completely clear is how that recording transpired,
like who set that bug?
How did that transcript get compiled?
Who hit record, on what device, and for what purpose?
That basically records the entire process
of murdering this journalist?
Well, what had happened, as I learned
in making "The Dissident" is they had decided,
that the Saudis, that they wanted
to rendition Jamal Khashoggi back to the Kingdom.
He was writing in the Washington Post,
not defending Trump and the Saudi regime.
Trump was a huge ally.
So he was speaking out against
US, Saudi relations and Trump.
He was working with a Saudi dissident in Canada,
basically fighting, Saudi Arabia's control of Twitter,
which is all part of the film,
and he had come out as speaking publicly
that he didn't agree with a lot of parts
of Mohammad bin Salman's vision 2030, which is his concept
of how to reform the Kingdom.
But everything that Jamal was writing about,
if you go back and read his Washington Post writings,
or even read books that he had published in Arabic,
is he was a moderate.
You couldn't even consider him liberal.
I mean, this was-
As just a reformist from inside the system.
Yeah, this was a moderate reformist who loved his country,
who had no problem with the monarchy.
He just believed because here was a guy
who had been educated in the United States.
He'd been coming to the us and to the UK his whole life,
most of the time working for the Saudi Royal family
as somebody who was either not a diplomat,
but a liaison.
He spoke fluent English, or as a journalist
for the Kingdom, writing about what was going on.
And so, this was a guy who really was entrenched
in that system and the family,
and so, his defection from was an insider
who really knew what was going on there, knew these people,
but he was portrayed all of a sudden Western media's
Muslim brotherhood as a terrorist sympathizer,
as a guy who knew Bin Laden and Al-Qaida and all this stuff,
and this was not true.
He was a moderate who loved his country
and what he was writing about wasn't down with Saudi Arabia
MBS must be overthrown, the royalty has no place,
the monarchy must abdicate the throne.
None of that was going on.
This was a guy who was going, "I love my country,
we have a young Prince who I believe is starting
to lead the country the wrong path.
He's talking about reforms, he's talking about,
okay, women can be able to drive and there isn't gonna be
the guardian system where women have to check in
with any man in the household who's 18 years or older
to get permission to leave the house.
And all these things that that Mohammad bin Salman
was talking about changing in the Kingdom,
and at the same time, he's completely crushing opinions.
He's crushing anybody who has anything critiquing of him,
just anybody who dares speaks anything other than this guy
is essentially the chosen perfect Monarch of all time.
And so what Jamal was really writing about was,
"Hey, we can do better, we can be better and you can be
a Monarch and also be kind.
You can be a Monarch and be compassionate.
You can be a King or a Prince and inspire your people
rather than repress them."
And that was the core of what he was doing,
and that descent led to a place where had he stayed
in Saudi Arabia, he surely would have been jailed,
and in leaving, he became hunted, and ultimately,
the decision was to murder him.
Right, so historically the relationship
between the monarchy and the press in Saudi Arabia
is kind of hagiography, right?
Your job is to basically speak kindly of what's happening
in the government, for the most part.
Exactly.
He was able to still advocate for some level of reform
within that construct and still covet favor
with those in power.
He kinda knew where that line was and how much he could push
without transgressing it.
But my sense is that, over time, beginning with Arab Spring
and kind of everything that happened after that,
he started to get a little bit more active,
pushing the buttons a little bit more,
a little bit more seeing where that line was,
and at one point, he crosses it perhaps even unbeknownst
to him and there's this edict that comes down
from the monarchy where they kind of disavow themselves
of him, right?
And then he realizes, basically he's fucked.
And he catches a flight out of the Kingdom that night
without telling anyone.
He could go back at some point,
but we all know he never did.
And you see in the film, we show some old clips of him
and you see him speaking in English and appearing
on Western media speaking in English.
And so he here is this guy who had spent his whole life
back and forth between the West and Saudi Arabia,
but he's in the Kingdom and he starts essentially
speaking out, not in any sort of like aggressive way,
but basically tweeting or writing,
"Hey, I don't agree with this."
or "Maybe this can be different."
And this guy was listened to,
he had 1.75 million followers on Twitter,
which it was a big number, especially in Saudi Arabia.
And so he was very respected.
So unlike, let's say, a young up and comer or this, that,
the other, this was now a very respected journalist,
coming out with his thoughts or opinions and somebody
who knew the inside workings.
And so Mohammed bin Salman had kind of put together
this whole, I guess, army as you'd call it, of people,
to basically see to it that, there were no free speech
or freedom of opinion in the Kingdom
and Saud al-Qahtan who was one of the Royal advisers,
basically apparently comes up with this plan
of how they are going to see to it
that there is no free speech in the Kingdom
and Saud reaches out to Jamal and tells them,
"Don't write, don't tweet, don't talk,
you're to remain silent.
And basically if you don't, we're gonna come
and arrest you."
And there's threats being made, and Jamal essentially
makes a decision that he has to leave.
He can't remain silent and this decision,
we get into in the film, but he was married,
he had children, his kids were living
in the United States at the time.
I didn't know about that.
And, two of the kids were in the US one of the kids
was in Saudi, was my understanding.
And he was happily married and he makes this decision
that he has to leave.
And he has to leave, I think for two reasons,
as I understand it, and his friends, who I got to know
in the making of a film, is that the idea that he would
sit there and be a lame duck and be silent,
and that his whole life was as a writer,
was as a journalist, that now his voice was silenced,
was enough that it was so compelling that he felt that
it was better to leave the country than to stay
with his family and be silenced.
And of course, I think, his family probably was not thrilled
with that decision.
And after he leaves he comes to Washington,
he gets a job being a Global Opinions writer
for the Washington Post.
And, there's a story, and I certainly can't validate
the truth of it for reasons,
but apparently, the Saudis come to his family, to his wife
and tell her that she has to divorce Jamal,
because only a husband can grant a divorce from his wife
and the Kingdom, women are not allowed to divorce,
a man has to grant a woman the right to divorce,
and apparently they brought her in and interrogated her
and whatever, and said, "You're going to call your husband
and tell him that he has to grant you a divorce."
And he did.
And he did because for her own good
so that they would leave the family alone.
And so he now was in Washington
and he was essentially isolated.
Yeah.
And that began the rebuilding of his life,
it began essentially, his ultimately finding
of Hatice Cengiz, the woman that he decided
that he was going to remarry, and that led to him
going into the consulate in Istanbul where he was murdered,
'cause he had went there to seek marriage papers,
to prove that he was no longer married
so that he can marry Hatice.
It's devastating.
The idea that he would leave his entire family
behind knowing he would never see them again.
Well, I think that he believed that...
Well, the kids were in Virginia and Washington,
two of them at the time.
They are now back in Saudi Arabia,
and I think they decided, in the aftermath of his murders,
that basically, they had two choices,
as I best understand it,
choice one was fight for justice for their father,
and the family would basically, never be able to travel,
be arrested, be ruined, right?
Because, how are you gonna take on this Kingdom?
And you have so many cousins and relatives and aunts
and uncles, I mean, so, so it was like,
"Okay, either we're gonna go fight for our father's death,
or we're gonna essentially accept a payout."
There's stories that the payout
was in the 10s of millions of dollars and remain silent
and move on with our lives.
And the family decided to go that route.
I can understand that,
because it wasn't just about the kids,
it was our aunts, our uncle's, our sisters, our brothers,
our cousins that, either we're going to...
Whatever war we rage or fight and trying to fight
for justice for our father is putting every member
of our family in danger, so I think ultimately,
the decision was made is okay, we'll go back to Saudi,
we'll shut up, we'll move past this
and we'll take the money.
In the structure of the film, it's very interesting,
the way you kind of set this up.
You have these two protagonists that are essentially
on a collision course with each other.
You've got Khashoggi and all the events that led
ultimately to his murder, but in parallel with that,
there's this other guy, Omar, who's left the Kingdom
and is living in Montreal and ultimately,
these two cross paths on this kind of trajectory
that Khashoggi is on from reformist journalist
to becoming, essentially, a full blown dissident.
So talk a little bit about how you structured the film,
because it really does, I mean, I haven't even said
this yet, but it's like, the film is extraordinary,
you did an unbelievable job, it's so compelling.
And it plays very much like a narrative thriller,
like on some level, it's more like a Bourne movie
than a documentary, like the score, all of the sound design,
every element of it is keeping you on pins and needles
the whole time, and there's like a Gestalt,
a tempo to the movie that really is very hyper-engaging
and unusual for a documentary.
Well, thank you.
That's certainly how we, myself and my creative partners
wanted the film to feel, sound, look, structured.
Is much like "Icarus", but in this heightened level,
I looked at this story and said, okay, it's a thriller.
It's all true, but this is a thriller.
The murder, the story of why he's murdered,
how he's murdered, all the forces that play, the characters,
this is like a Borne film.
And so there was a very intentional construction,
cinematically, and how we structured the film,
paste the film, put the film together,
and used these cinematic techniques that you would see
in "An Enemy of the State", or in those "Bourne" films,
or, you name the kind of the spy thriller movie
that were intentionally employed in the construction
of this film, while remaining true to being a documentary,
I mean, everything in the film, we shot,
everything in the film was a fact, everything in the film
is researched and archived and backed by evidence,
but structurally, my feeling as a filmmaker
and my collaborators, is I think, if you can engage
an audience visually, through sound, music, motion graphics,
effects, all these kind of devices,
that when you're watching like a big thriller,
gets you on the edge of your seat going,
what's gonna happen next?
And if you can do that, and especially in the case
of this story, that hopefully the come away
from watching, "The Dissident" isn't just that you're
on the edge of your seat and you're having
that kind of cinematic thriller esque experience,
but that it also leads to a call to action,
because you're emotionally impacted,
because you didn't just watch a piece of news,
you went on a journey, and that journey
becomes very emotional, hopefully, in watching the film
and that leads to what my intention would be
and is that there's a call to action behind it,
that you come out of the film and you fall in love
with Hatice Cengiz, his fiance.
You care about Omar Abdulaziz and that his brothers
are still jailed in Saudi with no charges,
and his friends are jailed in Saudi
for two years without charges, and this guy
lives in isolation, basically fighting the Kingdom
for freedom of speech.
You understand the truth behind this
and want to do something about it, as you see the members
of a G20 in the Trump administration essentially
bury their head in the sand and condone this murder,
all for all for money.
And so, hopefully, in the construction of the film,
being a thriller, that it also leads
to a greater emotional response,
and that was kind of the intention.
Yeah.
I mean, I knew the story.
I had read some of his pieces in in the Washington Post.
I had a familiarity with kind of the broader brushstrokes
of what had transpired.
What I was not aware of was one, focus of the film
being on on the extent of their surveillance state,
and how the Pegasus malware, and the hacking of the phones,
and how all of that, like played into
how that how this whole thing unfolded.
To back up, Khashoggi enter the consulate on October 2nd,
basically, two weeks later, I think it was the 16th,
Saudi Arabia finally admitted that he had, in fact,
died inside that consulate.
And in the film, there's kind of the whole story
of how that kind of unfolds, and the pressure
that Turkey put on Saudi Arabia to get them
to ultimately confess because they had the audio.
And I had been following this story, essentially,
from October 3.
Washington Post journalist vanishes
inside of Saudi consulate in Istanbul.
And I'm reading this story, as I think many
in the world began following this story in those two weeks,
and, each day was another shocking allegation,
and that he had been dismembered and that the body
was nowhere to be found, and that they won't let them
in the consulate and the-
Met with crazier and crazier excuses
on behalf of the Kingdom about what had happened.
Yeah, and I'm reading this and I remember,
'cause I'm pretty sure it was October 16th, 17th,
and I was in Rome at the time, I had been invited
to speak for the Rome Film Festival,
and I was with my fiance and I'd been following the story,
and as I started following that story, in those two weeks,
in my mind, I was going, maybe this is the next film
I wanna make.
This seemed to have all these ingredients,
'cause I had been looking, at that point, for about a year,
for what that next story I wanted to take on,
what that next documentary I wanted to make was,
and I felt kind of a lot of pressure and burden
coming out of "Icarus" that I wasn't gonna go
and direct a Disney film, I couldn't go, whatever,
make the Stevie Wonder documentary or whatever that was.
I was gonna have to, at least in my mind,
I wanted to see to it that I was taking on something
that was human rights, freedom of press,
freedom of journalism, protecting a whistleblower,
authoritarian regimes, dictatorships,
all these kind of themes that as a storyteller,
I wanted to be able to continue in that path.
And here was the story of a journalist,
and not only that, he's Washington Post journalist,
on his fighting for free speech, and he's advocating
for human rights, and he disagrees
with this authoritarian government, and he's at essentially
a war of words with the Crown Prince,
and now he's been murdered.
And I said, okay, this could be the one and the question
was, can I essentially get access to this story
to be able to tell it in a manner that isn't going
to be something that's archival?
And there were three things that really hinged on him,
which was one, there was the story of his fiancee
emerging of the girl, Hatice Cengiz was waiting
for him outside the consulate, and I said,
oh, wow, this is clearly the emotional core
of what this story is.
I mean, the concept, I mean, which is unfathomable to me,
it's unfathomable to anybody listening to this,
that the person that you love, that you believe
you're going to marry and spend your life with,
walks into a consulate, an embassy,
to be murdered horrifically, and that you're never
going to see them again.
And then at the same time, become, in Hatice's case,
the center of a global media storm.
And so all of a sudden, you become famous and famous
around the world to the point where you can't really
even leave your house, not because of something you did
that you're proud of, but because the person that you loved
has met this horrific fate.
And that, to me, was the first element that if I could get
Hatice to work with me, exclusively and share her story,
the love story, that there be a chance of being able
to really tell the story.
The second part of this was Omar Abdulaziz in Canada,
and the days following Khashoggi murder,
and the admission that Saudi Arabia, that he had died
inside that consulate, there's a story coming forward
in the New York Times of this young Saudi dissident
who was living in Montreal, Omar Abdulaziz
and he was saying, "I know why Jamal was killed.
In fact, I was hacked by Israeli cyber surveillance software
called Pegasus owned by the NSO Corporation,
and that Saudi Arabia had hacked my phone using
this software, Pegasus.
Jamal was hacked too, and because my phone had been hacked,
they knew that Jamal Khashoggi and I, had been working
on a project to basically take over the narrative
back on to Twitter."
As you'll see on the film, and if you read about this,
Saudi Arabia basically was manipulating
and still to this day manipulating Twitter,
which was the only platform in the Kingdom
where people could have freedom of speech and opinion,
because Twitter is a decentralized platform.
And if you create like different various Twitter accounts,
and you can create an account under a fake name,
or whatever you want, right, that you can voice expression,
and this was how the Arab Spring came to pass also.
And a big argument for why anonymity on Twitter
is something to be protected,
so these dissident voices can be heard.
Exactly.
And, sorry to interrupt, the point that you make,
I also didn't know is that 80% of Saudi Arabians
are on Twitter, whereas in the United States,
it's like 20%, or something.
Yeah, so Twitter, because the platform
is this kind of decentralized information platform,
and because you can kind of, whatever, you can have a VPN
and you can create a Twitter account
under whatever, your name is Bugs Bunny 21, right?
It has become on a global level,
in repressive authoritarian regimes, ways that kind of like
the resistance can communicate with each other,
and the Arab Spring only was able to happen
because of Twitter, because they were able to plan events,
they were able to plan marches plan, and Twitter
became that platform for dissidents to basically assemble.
And what these authoritarian regimes learned,
and these Arab governments, in the case of Saudi Arabia,
basically a dictatorship, a monarchy, which is similar
as it is in the Emirates and in Egypt, even though
it's now it's technically not a monarchy,
but it's a dictatorship,
is that if you could control Twitter, if you could control
the narrative on Twitter, you could crush freedom of speech,
you could crush opinion, and that you can
put forward your propaganda.
I mean, you even see this has happened
in the Trump administration over the last four years,
where Trump has used the authoritarian playbook
of using Twitter to basically bring forward
false information, whether it's about election fraud,
whether about voter fraud, whether it's about, you name it.
Trump has used Twitter as his platform to disseminate
false information, lies, right?
Well, these governments understand that Twitter
can be used for that, and so Saudi Arabia puts together
a plan to basically hire thousands and thousands
and thousands of people in the Kingdom,
to create false Twitter accounts and put forward
on to Twitter these false goals of the Kingdom.
"Mohammed bin Salman is a great reformer,
Mohammed bin Salman's vision 2030 is the best thing
to ever happen to Saudi Arabia.
Saudi Arabia is this, this, this and this."
Right?
And so Twitter is being flooded,
unbeknownst to the Saudi people, with tens and tens
of thousands of false tweets, all pro-government,
all basically, pushing forward this narrative.
Then, at the same time Saudi Arabia is spending,
depending on who you talk to, hundreds of millions
and billions of dollars with global PR agencies,
with the same thing, that Mohammed bin Salman
is the greatest thing to ever happen to Saudi Arabia, right?
Well, Omar Abdulaziz realizes that this is what is happening
on Twitter in Saudi Arabia, is not real.
These accounts are not real, these are fake accounts.
These are accounts basically owned and controlled
by the government of Saudi Arabia, to put forward
false opinions and lies and false narratives
about the Kingdom.
At the same time, what these accounts are doing,
is that anybody like let's say, Omar Abdulaziz
or Jamal Khashoggi puts forward a tweet saying,
"I disagree with Mohammed bin Salman, I think this.",
that these Saudi Twitter trolls are flies this army
of thousands, tens of thousands of people
that have been hired to basically take control of Twitter,
all of a sudden flood this dissenters
or person's Twitter account with "Screw you, you should die,
this isn't true.", right?
And so suddenly, their tweet is completely suppressed,
like it doesn't exist, and everything that is trending
in the Kingdom on Saudi Arabia is pro-government,
pro-monarchy, pro-MBS.
So Jamal and Omar are working on basically a plan
that they call The Bees Army, to take control of the flies,
where they're gonna basically do the same thing
that the Saudis have been doing on Twitter,
except they're going to get dissidents within the Kingdom
and everywhere to for them to create tons and tons
of fake Twitter accounts, but their fake Twitter accounts
will be basically putting forward freedom of speech,
human rights, right?
And that ultimately, this will be the war between
the bees and the flies.
Right.
That two can play a this game.
You wanna put forward your false propaganda?
All right, we'll put forward the truth
and we'll tell the people what's really happening.
So, because Omar's phone is hacked with Pegasus,
and because Jamal's phone is hacked with Pegasus,
Saudi Arabia knows what these two are up to,
and that they are basically trying
to reclaim control of Twitter.
And this, arguably, is the biggest, probably single reason
why they decide to murder Jamal, 'cause it's one thing
that Jamal is writing in the Washington Post,
which was negative, but it's another thing
if all of a sudden he and Omar and this army of dissidents
basically can take back control of Twitter,
and Twitter is the way that Saudi Arabia gets their news.
This is so fundamental to the Kingdom in their narrative.
And in the hacking of the phone, they're able to understand
that Jamal is not only just writing in the Washington Post,
they're able to understand that he's now working
with a known dissident to take back control of Twitter.
And I think that this was probably the breaking point
where they decided that he needed to be murdered,
and they had tried to come to Canada and rendition Omar
just months earlier.
Those two dudes show up and try to cajole him
into returning with promises that he'll get his own TV show
and that MBS loves him, but it's Khashoggi who's saying,
"Don't do that, you don't wanna do that.
It's a trap."
That's right, and yet Khashoggi falls into the same trap
and he falls into the same trap, the backs up so they had
agents basically came to Canada with Omar's brother
in tow, basically is like a hostage, like,
"Hey, Omar, if you don't come back to Saudi Arabia
and we love you.", which of course was not true at all,
"Just know that we've got your brother."
And Omar chooses not to go back to Saudi Arabia,
and after making that decision, they arrest his brothers,
19 years old and the other brother's a couple years older,
and they have remained in the Saudi prison and tortured
without charges for the last two years
and 33 of his friends, just people that were linked to him,
not dissidents, nothing just just by knowing Omar
is basically this rendition tool of,
"Hey, if you want your brothers to get out of jail,
if you want your friends to get out of jail,
you need to either be silent, or you need
to come back to Saudi Arabia."
Where, you're either going to be imprisoned
or be silenced, right?
And so that Omar has not happened, that Omar has continued
to fight, so.
Yes, he's still doing his YouTube show.
I mean, I checked his Twitter account last night,
and he's got over a half million people now.
Yeah, he's got a half a million followers
and what happens on his YouTube shows, every time you posts
an episode, the Kingdom and their lawyers basically,
say that, whatever it is, like he's using copyrighted
material is using news-
They get it pulled down.
Like things and they get it pulled down
and so then he has to put it up somewhere else
and they get it pulled down, but if you go
on to his YouTube station, you'll see that it gets
pulled down, it goes back up and there's,
I don't know, hundreds of thousands of followers
that watch his essentially show, which is kind of like,
a, I don't know how you would best describe it,
a coal bear, a camel, (indistinct).
It's like what Bassem Youssef did in Egypt,
are you familiar with him?
He was sort of the Jon Stewart of Egypt.
I've heard the name, but I haven't-
Leading up to Arab Spring, he lives in the US now
and he's been on the podcast, but it's a similar
kind of situation.
Yeah, where Omar's the first guy
to kind of create a show which is criticizing
the Kingdom, making jokes.
He's taking kind of like looking at like
at US style talk shows, and does the show
as often as he can,
looking at all the Saudi Daily News and looking
at all the Saudi Twitter feeds and all the false narratives
then he puts together the show going like,
"Okay, that's a lie, that's a lie, that's a lie,
that's a lie, that's a lie, that's a lie, that's a lie.
And also, we've seen a lot of comedy into it
and he's doing even sketches and things like that.
Wow.
And correct me if I'm wrong, but but Jamal's murder
seems to almost perfectly coincide
with the Bees actually succeeding in getting
their message and their hashtags to trend number one
on Twitter, like those seem to almost happen
at the exact same moment.
Simultaneously.
Yeah.
And I don't believe that that was an accident,
it was, as this was taking steam, I think the decision
was made within the Kingdom of we're going
to send a message.
And when you understand that their phones were hacked,
right, then, as you'll see in the film, and in understanding
the story behind this, you can see how that danger grew.
And I think, Jamal, couldn't imagine, he couldn't believe
that his own country could do that to him.
And he had actually went about a month before his murder,
because he was going back and forth between Washington DC
and Istanbul, where he's now with Hatice Cengiz.
Yeah, Hatice lives there, right?
Right.
And so they had decided that they were going
to have a life in both places.
He bought an apartment or a condo for them in Istanbul,
and they were gonna split their time,
they were gonna be together in Istanbul,
then she'd come to Washington and study and he'd
go back to Istanbul, so he had bought
a place for them in Istanbul.
And he had originally went to the consulate
in Washington, D.C. and actually met
with the Saudi Ambassador to the US at the time,
who was Mohammed bin Salman's brother, right?
And he goes into the consulate in Washington, D.C.
asking for these marriage papers.
And they say, "We're happy to give you these papers,
no problem at all, but you need to get them in Istanbul.
You wanna marry a Turkish woman, you need to get them
at the consulate in Istanbul.", right?
So he comes out of this meeting in Washington,
kind of being welcomed.
He's met with the Prince's brother,
who he already knew, right?
And he's assured everything's fine, no big deal,
you just need to go get them in Istanbul.
So, when he goes into the consulate in Istanbul
the first time, they welcome him, they're nice to him,
but they say, "Oh, hey, we need to prepare these papers."
But they knew that he was gonna be coming
to that consulate in Istanbul already.
So they go, "Okay, now we got a shot at him."
Because they weren't gonna do it
on Americans soil.
Exactly.
Right.
They weren't gonna do it on American soil.
And the bifurcation,
like you're gonna have to come back in five days,
allowed them to get their plan in motion
and get these guys out from the Kingdom
to be in the consulate when he arrived.
Exactly.
But he was nervous.
He brought Hatice with him the first time, both times.
Both times.
Because he wasn't quite certain that it was gonna be okay.
Well, not only that, he left his phones and his computer
and everything with Hatice, 'cause the both times
that he went in, he basically left everything with with her
and said, "Hey, if something happens to me,
here's (indistinct) information,
here's these people to call."
And so, he goes in the first time and they're nice,
they're warm to him, and they say,
"No problem, Jamal, we'll give you the paperwork.
We just need a few days, come back in a week."
And so he leaves kind of going, "Okay, everything's okay."
Right.
And that gives them this week
to essentially plan his murder.
And he goes back a week later, and he was murdered.
But clearly, I mean, him leaving his devices
with the Hatice was even on his return back in
there was, I'm sure, that part of him going like,
okay, here's my phone, here's my this and in the transcript
of his murder, which we have in the film,
and to this day, that transcript has not been released.
There's only a few people in the world that have it.
It's CIA, British intelligence, the French,
the Turks, of course, and me,
and there's a whole story behind
how I finally obtained the transcript.
And in this transcript, he makes note that he doesn't have
his phones on him.
He's asked to send a message to his son telling him
that he's okay, and that if he doesn't hear from him
for a few days, not to worry, and he doesn't have
his phones with him, and he even says,
"My fiance is waiting for me outside."
And so those devices in his computer and everything
were brought into evidence, and I've been told
that they did find Pegasus on those devices.
The transcript is horrific, I mean, it's gut wrenching.
What's interesting is the Saudis were able
to delay the investigation for something
like two weeks, right?
I think it was the 15th of October before they finally
let the Turks into the consulate?
Yeah, there abouts.
Something like that.
It was a good two weeks and yeah, and in those two weeks,
of course, they were able to clean up the murder scene.
Not quite as well as they should have.
What's interesting in the transcript also,
and I don't get into this in the film in great detail,
but in the five or six days from the time
he first enters the consulate, and then goes back
and returns, Saudi Arabia puts this mission
into kind of high motion, and they actually bring
two different teams, they're ahead of the murder.
One of the teams, two days before he's murdered
is to sweep the consulate for listening devices for bugs,
and they don't find one, and the listening device
was only in this one room
where they had secure communications,
and we still don't know to this day
how that listening device got there, whose device it was,
was it the Turks?
Was in another country who handed it over to the Turks?
Not sure.
That's super interesting, 'cause, yeah,
that's never explained in the film
and never we've had an explanation for who recorded it.
And the Turks will never tell you how they got it.
Uh huh.
That prosecutor is like a badass.
He is like, out of like a "Bourne" film, isn't he?
I know, and his accent is unbelievable.
I mean, he's every filmmaker dream,
and he's never spoken on camera about the crime.
To this day, I don't think there's a single interview
out there of him other than what you'll see
in "The Dissident", and, I think he carries a heavy burden
with this case, in particular.
In the wake of all of this becoming global news,
you have MBS back in the Kingdom, trying to figure out
how he's gonna control this narrative
that is quickly eluding his ability to manipulate, right?
Which gets us into the Pegasus hack of Bezos' phone,
which is fascinating.
We all remember when his personal pictures
got leaked, was it the Post, the New York Post
who published those?
It was the Enquirer.
Oh, it was Enquirer, yeah.
Yeah, and basically, there were stories coming out
that Bezos is having an affair, and that there's photos
that we're essentially gonna be published of selfies
that he had sent to Lauren Sanchez,
and there was even a apparently nude or, and-
And then he pulls like the baller move of the century
by getting ahead of it and making
all of that available to anybody who would wanna see it.
He basically puts together this post on Medium
going, "Here's what's happened.
I was hacked, my phone was hacked,
and I'm not gonna be blackmailed.
And they were trying to blackmail me
and this is all a blackmail extortion attempt,
because I own the Washington Post,
and the Saudis are mad at me."
Because the Saudi Arabia, to back up Bezos
on the Washington Post and in the fallout of the murder
of Jamal Khashoggi, right, Khashoggi wrote for the post,
so the post has the biggest knife in the fight,
and they are pushing this story forward.
And the fascinating thing behind the Khashoggi murder,
what got the world's involved was, had Jamal been painted
in the press in the media, as "Saudi journalist
enters consulate in Istanbul killed", right?
It would have fallen on deaf ears,
but because it's an American paper, the New York Times,
Washington Post, right?
And they're putting forward this story
that it's not Saudi journalist,
it's a Washington Post journalist.
So now Jamal is essentially an American,
and this catches the world's attention.
Had he not been a Washington Post journalist,
because in all the news, it wasn't Saudi journalist,
it was Washington Post journalist,
and here's this publication that he had worked for, right?
And that's what caught the world's attention,
it was Washington Post journalist, and so what MBS
couldn't, I guess separate in his mind is the idea
that you can own a newspaper and not have control
of the newspaper, right?
Right.
So just because you own the New York Times
doesn't mean in the United States that you control
the New York Times.
If you're a free paper, right, you don't have control
over what the paper actually writes.
I'm sure there's whatever, I mean for Fox News
is basically putting forward its thing,
but ultimately, there is still a freedom of press there.
So the Washington Post's is pushing this forward,
this story forward globally, and making
the Khashoggi murder, a huge, huge global story.
They're running ads in the paper, full page ads in the paper
behind the murder, they're putting up billboards,
the Washington Post is not letting this story die,
and MBS in his mind is going "Well, hey, Jeff Bezos,
you own the Washington Post, you can make this stop."
Yeah, kill it, and behind the scenes,
those guys had been in communication with each other.
Exactly.
'Cause MBS was trying to get Amazon up on its feet
in the Kingdom.
Right, so they had business dealings together,
there was a whole deal for,
I don't know billions of dollars of a Cloud server
that Amazon was gonna do with the Kingdom,
and lo and behold, MBS hacks Bezos, his phone with Pegasus,
or we think it's Pegasus, but he had actually been hacked
before the Khashoggi murder.
So he had been sending Bezos' messages,
and all of a sudden, Bezos gets this video message
of a soccer match, and Saudi Arabia versus,
I can't remember, Norway, and Bezos clicks on this message,
and it's like, what is this message?
He's kind of perplexed by it, but lo and behold,
that was hacking his phone, and so in the fallout
of the Khashoggi murder, as all of a sudden Bezos'
affair is being leaked to the public,
Bezos springs on an investigation team
of forensic cyber examiner's who go into his devices,
and they're watching the data stream out of his phone,
and linking it to a server known to be a Saudi server,
and so, you go, okay, well, how else
was this information coming public?
He was clear that he had been hacked,
and, yeah, so you go, okay, if you can hack
the richest man in the world, who can't you get?
Right, I mean, that's the kind of scary message
that you leave everyone with, nobody is out of bounds here.
Nobody is out of bounds, and I think one of the themes
in the film is the battlegrounds of the world right now,
are not being fought with weapons, it's being fought
in cyber sphere, and these are the biggest weapons
in the world right now.
You look at the NotPetya virus, a couple years ago,
in the Ukraine, that was a Russian virus.
It shut down the entire power grids in the Ukraine,
and basically completely hobbled the Ukraine,
and all these major shipping companies,
Andy Greenberg writes about this
in his book called "Sandworm".
And a lot of people don't know this story,
but this was the single biggest cyber attack
in the world's history so far against the Ukraine,
because it crippled all the global shipping agencies,
it crippled FedEx and basically infected their systems
and brought down these companies to their knees
for this period of time, and cost billions and billions
of dollars, and to this day, people don't even
realize what happened, and this was a cyber attack.
Or, in the case of these cyber firms like NSO,
is what you read and what you learn is that
there is hacking software.
There was an idea a few years ago, okay, Apple
and the government trying to get Apple
to turn over codes and stuff, they don't need that anymore.
There is now private software being developed
by private companies, in this case, this is a company
called NSO out of Israel.
All of these sales have to get approved
by the Israeli government, but Israel basically,
is allowing the sale of this software
to pretty much any government in the world,
because when they sell this software,
Israeli intelligence is also gaining insight
into who each one of these companies wants to hack.
So okay, so Israel and NSO sells Pegasus
to the Saudis, right?
And you can well, why would Israel want Saudi Arabia
to have this hacking technology?
Well, not only is lucrative and they're paying millions
of dollars for these licenses, but on the back end, right,
NSO and Israeli intelligence, are able to know
who Saudi Arabia is hacking, who they're after,
what they're touching.
So, I mean, it's really nutty, but what you understand
is that this technology is also now in private hands.
And much like what Snowden unveiled to the world,
with what our government was doing and what the NSA
was doing and in listening into people's devices,
and all the information he brought forward,
what you're seeing is that this is even much worse
than we can imagine, because governments around the world,
essentially, with just somebody's phone number,
can go in and hack somebody's device, take control
of that device, know everything about that person,
and this is a completely unregulated part
of the cyber landscape, that there is no regulation
in this regard, other than, the United States
knows that the Saudis have this technology
and they know the Emirates have this technology,
and the Emirates knows that other countries
have this technology.
And the ability to destabilize geopolitics and do it,
essentially invisibly is so potent and frightening, right?
And what's interesting about this is it shares
a common theme with with "Icarus" in that this search
for a competitive advantage, creates a situation
in which the advantage is always ahead
of the detection method, right?
In the sense that doping is always kind of two steps
ahead of our ability to detect it and creates
this sort of tension between those two competing entities.
Here, we have cyber warfare, just miles ahead of our ability
to even understand it, let alone preemptively
get in front of it.
Yeah, I mean, that's an interesting analogy,
I never really thought about it that way.
That's a really good and interesting analogy,
which is, I think what we see as a society in technology,
is every time we have a newer technology,
another thing unleashed, it's incredible, in some sense,
and on the same hand, it's that more invasive
and invasive technique.
And you can look at this across all these platforms
even like Google, right?
Okay, so Google buys Nest cameras, right?
And so now, if you have a Nest camera,
the only way to actually have other people have access
to the Nest, is to integrate it in
through Google Home, but your Google Home account
is linked to your Gmail account, and your Gmail account,
and your Google account is linked
to all your web searches and everything.
I mean, so you go, oh, my God, what kind of information
does Google have on me?
They have access to my home, they have access to my cameras,
they have access...
You know if your Ring or Nest, right?
They have access to my security systems, they have access
to my web searches, they have access to my emails,
they have...
Right?
And so you have, A, these companies, whether that's Facebook
and Instagram, and...
I mean, the other day, I was literally thinking of going
and taking a trip and was trying to figure out
where to go and, I did a search for the Bahamas, right?
And all of a sudden on Instagram yesterday,
I'm getting ads about resorts in the Bahamas.
Really going, what?
Yeah.
Why am I Instagram Feed of resorts
in the Bahamas coming up?
And yet, there they are.
The scarier thing is when you just say it out loud,
you don't do a search and then you get the ads.
Right, Siri, Google Assistant, all that stuff.
So you have like Sonos speakers and you're looking
up your Google Assistant to go,
"Hey, Google Play Led Zeppelin."
Right?
And then the next thing you're doing, you're seeing,
buy the Led Zeppelin box set.
When you interviewed the cyber security
expert dude, that kind of figured out that Omar's phone
had been hacked, did you have him look at your phone?
John Railton Scott, yes.
Yeah
Yeah, I've had my devices looked at.
I have a monitoring device on my phone,
which is actually, hopefully, would show if all of a sudden
my phone starts pinging towers
that it isn't supposed to ping.
So the way that they look to figure out
if you've been hacked, right, is it's not like,
oh, you've got some virus in your phone,
and like, I think the way the most people think about,
oh, I've been hacked, or I'm getting malware of crashing,
the way that cybersecurity experts look
at where you've been, if you've been hacked,
is apparently, our phones really only communicate
to a handful, and I don't know what that handful is,
whether that's 100, 200, whatever it is,
kind of global satellites and servers.
Google and Apple, and Amazon and all these different
servers and satellites that essentially are in control
of all data and communications, right?
So your phone is pinging like this satellite, right?
Or pinging this server connected to a satellite,
whatever the technical thing of it, I'm messing up,
but, right, but it's not that many.
Like, so, okay, if we're going on Amazon, right?
It's going there, or no matter what that search is,
because our search engines, right, it's like, okay,
it's Google, it's Safari, it's whatever that is,
Firefox or something like that, and so everything
that we're doing on our phones, or our Apple or Android,
right, are ultimately going through these different massive
infrastructure, servers, satellites.
So the way that they figure out if you've been hacked,
is if all of a sudden there's information
coming from your phone to essentially a satellite server,
right, that is not part of one of these big servers,
'cause there's no reason why your phone
would be communicating with that server.
And if what they're watching when they are looking
at your phone is all of a sudden you have data
being extracted out of your phone,
that your uploads are much more than your downloads,
'cause why would your uploads be more than your downloads?
Right?
You're downloading-
You're pulling information, yeah.
Not uploading information out of your phone,
and it's communicating with one of these servers,
which they don't know.
That's how they're looking at whether or not
a hack has happened.
It would seem relatively elementary to have an app
that could run a diagnostic on that,
and let you know if something is awry.
Well, it's more complicated than that now,
because basically, you would need to as like,
John Railton Scott, who is the Citizen Lab in Canada,
and they're the ones who figured out that Omar
had been hacked with Pegasus and the way
that they figured out that Omar had been hacked
with Pegasus, and they actually are, one of the people,
if not the people that discovered Pegasus,
and they've published other hacks and Pegasus
and other people who've been targeted,
and if you go in and research, The Citizen Lab,
out of Canada, out of Toronto, the Munk School,
in Toronto, is where they're funded,
is they in their research, we're basically looking
at information streaming to these servers
that they identified as not being part
of all these ones that are legitimate, right?
Where your traffic would flow from Apple,
right, or Google.
And in identifying these servers, they were able
to start identifying the use of these servers,
and so in the case of Omar, you when they got his device,
they were seeing that essentially, there was a device
in Canada, right, communicating with one of these servers
that they had deemed to be a Saudi server
that they believed was using Pegasus software.
And so I guess the the back end of this is understanding
what all these servers are, where they are,
and they're always changing too.
So the game, kind of like the doping thing
that you say is that it's always you're only as good
as you were today, but if a new substance comes out,
that's unable to avoid detection, or a new super drug,
right, well, you wouldn't test positive
even though you're positive, because it's undetectable,
which is much like, okay, you're going to test
for breast cancer, right?
Well, the test for breast cancer is this test, right?
You're gonna test this, this and this,
and if that doesn't show up, then, well,
then you don't have breast cancer,
but if there's a new strain of breast cancer,
which they haven't developed a test for,
or that they don't know about yet, right,
you would test negative for breast cancer,
even though you might have breast cancer, hypothetically,
or for anything.
Well, the same applies to doping and substances,
that you can't detect something
unless you're being tested for that, and the same
in the world of cyber and hacking,
is that okay, they're going to plug in
all the known variables, but if there's a new variable,
a new server, a new technology, a new, right,
they're not gonna know if you've been hacked.
Yeah.
It is really frightening.
Unbelievable, yeah, yeah.
Amazingly, in the wake of all of this,
we see politicians standing up calling for action
to do the right thing, and we're talking about people
like Lindsey Graham and Rand Paul, right?
And yet, we then see you kind of conclude the film
with Trump vetoing any kind of deleterious action
that would harm the Kingdom.
So, where does that leave us geopolitically?
What do you make of how this whole thing kind of shook out?
Well, to backtrack into that, what we see
in the film, is that there has been no punishment
for Saudi Arabia for the murder of Jamal Khashoggi,
there has been no meaningful sanctions taken,
not only in the United States, but by all members
of the G20.
And what we see was there was bipartisan support
from both the Republicans and the Democrats
to have sanctions to stop weapon sales
to Saudi, to basically, attempt to stop the war in Yemen,
and that ultimately, the Trump administration
vetoed all these actions, and in Bob Woodward's book
that he just published, where he had recorded
all these conversations with Trump,
Trump actually flat out said,
and he said, "I saved MBS's ass."
So this is actually something that Trump is proud of,
that he basically protected the relationship with himself
or the United States, however you wanna look at it
and Saudi Arabia, by not punishing Mohammed bin Salman
for the murder of Jamal Khashoggi,
or in stopping weapons sales or standing up
against the war in Yemen.
So, this is something that the Trump administration
is very proud of, despite what you've seen
as bipartisan support in the United States,
to basically take action to reassess
the US relationship with Saudi Arabia.
Joe Biden, actually on the second year anniversary
of Jamal's murder, which just passed on October 2,
put out a statement, saying, "if I'm elected President",
he's now been elected President, "One of one of the things
that I'll be doing is reassessing the US-Saudi relationship,
looking at sanctions, looking at action."
And he basically sent out a tweet, "Justice for Jamal,
and even since he's been President elect,
he's said again, that he is planning to, really dive
into US-Saudi relations,
in light of all their human rights abuses
and what's happening in the Kingdom.
So, there appears to possibly be
some sort of positive outcome coming from this,
but to date, you have seen no member state of the G20
and or the United States take any action against this
and this really just speaks to, I think,
the global economic relationship of Saudi Arabia
and the world.
Unlike, let's say a country, even like Russia, right?
Where the economic stakes are not as high
because of the investment.
What we see out of the Kingdom is because Saudi Arabia
has the single largest sovereign wealth fund in the world,
meaning that they have more money to invest
into other essentially countries and buy stuff
in any other country.
And they are so liquid in their investments,
they're also basically, all the money in SoftBank,
the world's largest hedge fund, is Saudi money, right?
That not just governments, but companies around the world,
don't know how to say, no, to the investment,
and in case of this film-
Yeah, which that leads me into the question
around distribution of this movie and how you financed it.
We have fought a real uphill battle.
In the making of a film, The Human Rights Foundation,
Thor Halvorssen, who started the foundation,
Garry Kasparov is its CEO, decided to fund the film,
because the Human Rights Foundation actually
had invited Jamal Khashoggi to one of its freedom forums
called the Oslo Freedom Forum, that they host every year
in Oslo where they bring together dissidents
from all over the world that have either
fled their countries or escaped from their countries,
to come and speak about these oppressive regimes
and what's going on in their country.
And so the work of the Human Rights Foundation
aligns with this film, and they have helped to fund
and give voice to dissidents all over the world,
from oppressive regimes and fighting for freedom of speech
and democracies and whether the (indistinct) in China,
or whether it's what's been going on in Venezuela,
or whether it's oppression in Russia, or you name it,
the Human Rights Foundation and their mandate
is basically to try to protect human rights
and freedom of speech and democracies,
and fight against authoritarian dictatorships.
And so, when I decided I wanted to make this film
Thor Halvorssen and I met through a mutual friend,
and he said, "I actually met Jamal.
He was at the Oslo Freedom Forum back in May,
and he was murdered in October."
And, we've been talking to Omar Abdulaziz to invite him
to an Oslo Freedom Forum and iyad el-Baghdadi,
who you see in the film is a another dissident,
actually spoken many times at the Oslo Freedom Forums,
and involved with the Human Rights Foundation.
We'd love to do this.
And so they came in and backed the film,
and have been my partners and making the film.
And we premiered the film at Sundance, which, it's so crazy
that that was nine, 10 months ago,
and it was just before COVID.
It was like the last (indistinct).
Just before (indistinct), literally.
Yeah, exactly.
As soon as you got home, clamped down.
Boom, and apparently Sundance now turns out
to be like a super spreader of that, right?
Right, (laughs) that's right.
And at our premiere, there is Hillary Clinton
came to the premiere and Alec Baldwin and each time
we show at Sundance, we have standing ovations.
And the most incredible reviews of I've ever read
from the trades and the critics that were there,
I was really taken back by them, and we come out of Sundance
in the top 10 films of Hollywood Reporter,
in the top 10 variety, in the top eight of AP
and all these incredible accolades,
to not a single offer of distribution, not one.
That speaks louder than words.
Not a penny being offered for the film.
Not $1.
Nothing.
That is so crazy.
And here is the company that I did "Icarus" with,
that I believe is my partner's, silence.
Here's Amazon and Jeff Bezos and me believing
that well, Bezos would have a knife in this fight.
Yeah, you think he'd be the number one choice.
Silence.
And every one of the major global streamers, global media,
entertainment companies, studios, that could have acquired
and given life to this film, silence.
And what we see here is essentially that the dollar,
the Saudi investment, the potential to grow in that region,
to gain subscribers into Saudi Arabian here,
Netflix took off Hasan Minhaj's show for criticizing MBS.
They pulled like a whole episode, right?
They pulled out a whole episode, and just a few weeks ago,
they announced an eight-slate deal with Saudi Arabia.
Is Saudi Arabia invested in Netflix?
Are they an equity partner in that company?
I have no idea, but I think what we see and it speaks
not just to Netflix, it's across the board,
is that human rights and freedom of speech
isn't just in danger and being suppressed
in places like Saudi Arabia, it's here in the United States,
where essentially, our economic interest,
and these interests of these massive companies
that have the ability to disseminate information,
that have the ability for a global audience
to see something and learn and take action
and stand up against forces like this
and bring about change, are choosing
their business interests and economic interest
and their shareholder interest, over what their audiences
actually would want to see,
or would want to see on top of seeing "Love is Blind".
And so, we're in a moment here, where these companies
have grown so big and so powerful,
and we're in this huge, global landscape,
whereas, years ago, you could go,
okay, hey, you're a company, and you're just distributing
the film to The United States, so you're like,
okay, we can put this out in the United States, no problem.
But now the formula is global and so nobody wants
to put something out with the idea that,
oh, you might upset China, you might upset Russia,
you might upset Saudi, you might upset Egypt,
you might upset Brazil, wherever you call it.
And so the appetite for content that actually
is taking on subject matters such as this,
over the last couple years, has been completely
and utterly diminished, and these companies
are now operating much in the way of like,
a government, where you're going, "Okay,
do we punish the murder of Alexander Litvinenko?
Well, if we do that, what are we doing?
Are we starting a war with Russia?
No, we're not gonna do that.
Are we gonna stop doing business with Russia?
Are we going to sanction Russia to the tune of gazillions
of dollars so that it hurts our economies?
No, we're not gonna do that."
So ultimately, we go, "All right, we'll let you get away
with murdering this dissident on foreign soil."
And just like what has happened in the Khashoggi murder,
where essentially they've been able to get away with it
because of the amount of money in business and investment,
we're seeing this stretch way beyond governments
and it's now in these media companies and corporations,
where a couple months ago, Amazon announced
that they were acquiring Souk.
Souk was essentially the Amazon of Saudi Arabia, right?
Right.
So, now Amazon owns Souk, so Amazon controls, right?
Commerce in the Kingdom.
Wow.
And so ultimately the decision was, okay,
acquire "The Dissident" or continue on billions of dollars
of business that we're gonna do in the Kingdom.
Yeah, it's not-
We'll do the business in the-
It's not a difficult economic decision to make
and it's amazing that we can all rally
around a free speech issue when it's confronted
with a government that is trying to clamp down on it
by way of of laws, right?
But here we are in the West, where we technically
have freedom of speech, and yet economic interests
are creating this unbelievable chilling effect
on the free exchange of ideas, and it's happening
right underneath our eyes.
We're seeing this progressive restriction as a result
of those economic tectonic plates,
but also from the people themselves.
It's like we're policing ourselves when it comes
to free speech.
So it's a very different conversation around free speech
than that, which, we're talking about when we look
at places like Saudi Arabia.
I have many friends who will go unnamed,
that had various projects in development
with these major media companies that looked at things
on human rights levels, on political levels,
on stories such as this and that these global streamers
have all basically said, "No, we're not gonna do
these stories anymore."
I have heard stories of unnamed companies,
but among these companies that basically have had
shareholder meetings, or they have discussed
in these meetings that anything that is political,
anything that we're to take on the Trump administration,
or we're to take on China or to go against, you name it,
we're no longer interested in.
And the reason being is because the growth in these regions,
right, is more important than the human rights
in these regions.
And so, ultimately, if you can expand, let's say,
and have millions of subscribers in Saudi Arabia,
a wealthy country, and have all this revenue
from Saudi Arabia, versus showing these awful
human rights abuses in the country, well,
you're gonna take the money over what is ethics
and morality, and I think it's been a rude awakening
to me as a filmmaker and as an activist
to think that, but this is kind of happening,
because I view that those who have wealth and power,
in a perfect world, especially in the Western world,
should be the ones who are standing up
and having the strength to shed light for the world,
into places where people are being oppressed or suppressed.
And just like you see with the NBA in China,
or ESPN in China, being able to walk away
from all these abuses, or what China has been doing
in Hong Kong, yet, all these companies
are still doing business with China, despite them trying
to turn Hong Kong into into a dictatorship, right?
And yet, nobody's willing to stop doing business with them.
And we're seeing this across the board,
and it's disheartening for someone like me,
who wants to continue to make films like this
and bring stories like this forward, having to struggle
to have this content seen, and I would have thought
that having had the honor of winning an Academy Award
would have changed that.
Right, given you a little bit more latitude
and door swinging wide open at Netflix.
You would think.
But that is not the case.
And then on the other hand, you can see this
from the company's perspective, right?
You're watching "The Dissident", how Jeff Bezos
is able to be hacked.
You watch how somebody is able
to be chopped up and murdered.
So if you're that company, right, on the flip side,
you can imagine those internal conversations
of going like, "I don't want them to hack us,
I don't want them to hack my company,
I don't want them to take down my servers,
I don't want them to launch a Twitter campaign against us,
I don't wanna-"
Right, and then not that you need to covet favor with MBS,
but no need to antagonize him when there's so much
business opportunity to be had potentially in the future.
Right, and there's so much risk to be had
by taking that on, and I think
that that equation ultimately,
I don't think the word is bad decision making,
I think leads into risk assessment analysis.
And each one of these companies or corporations,
there's risk assessment, and that risk assessment
announcement is, "Okay, on one hand, whatever,
hundreds of millions of people will see the film,
and there'll be accolades and it'll be this, that
and the other.
On the other hand, maybe x, y, z can happen.
Another filmmaker I admire, Ryan White,
who did "The Keepers", did a film this year
called "Assassins", and it's on the murder
of Kim Jong Il's half-brother in Malaysia,
by the two women that basically poisoned him
at the airport, right?
And you, it's North Korea.
Again, Ryan's film, nobody has stepped up on a global level
to distribute this.
It's being distributed by a small distributor, and-
I've never heard of it.
Yeah, that's a great film.
And again, he was at Sundance, and the story
is the exact story of "The Dissident"
which is, all of these global streamers in here,
Ryan had had tremendous success with "The Keepers"
in Netflix, right?
And ultimately, they went, oh, well, the Sony hack, right,
was the North Koreans, and that was really embarrassing
for Sony and this was over film, "The Interview",
which was a comedy.
And it's all these global streamers going like,
okay, they hacked Sony, they messed him up,
screw it, it doesn't matter that "Assassin"
is an important film, it doesn't matter
that it's inside into North Korea, it doesn't matter
that it shows how what this is, not for us.
We don't want the risk.
And so I think there has to be a re-imagining
for storytellers or activists that want to see to it
that their content can be globally seen,
and maybe a new platform is ultimately created
that allows us, but the counter to this
is Briarcliff Entertainment, Tom Wartenberg
who was running Lions Gate and then Open Road
and did "Spotlight", and did "Crash"
and did "Fahrenheit 9/11", and has been a real champion
for difficult films that came forward, about six months ago,
and acquired the film, and so "The Dissident",
we planned that it was gonna come out into theaters,
that it was gonna go on 1,000 screens on October 2nd,
and of course, with COVID, that wasn't gonna happen.
So then we changed the plan again to December 18th,
and we're still in COVID, so that's not happening.
So now it's coming out in limited theaters,
where theaters are open, December 25,
and on January 8th, it will launch across
all on demand platforms where people can rent the movie,
so it will be on iTunes, it will be on Amazon for purchase,
it will be on Xbox and Roku and FireStick
and Comcast and DirecTV, and all those places.
So I'm optimistic that it'll find its way,
it's not going to be in front of a couple hundred
million subscribers with a subscription to Netflix,
but it will make its way into the world.
Yeah, it'll find its way and so the December 25th
limited release, is before the year turns over,
is for Oscar consideration, right?
Isn't that still the thing, it has to premiere
in a theatrical way before?
That's my understanding, yes.
Yeah, I think you're right
and then it'll be available after that.
January and luckily, our partnership with the,
I guess they call it PVoD, paid on-demand, company vertical
is for the longest time, I think it was a 45-day window.
If you launched in a theater, you couldn't have it
on-demand within 45 days, but with COVID,
all of the rules are changing now, and so we're able
to come into theaters on December 25 and be available
for on-demand on January 8th.
So, it's excited for the film to be seen
'cause I really I just...
Hatice Cengiz, Jamal's fiance,
I mean, she's become like a sister to me,
and for me, this film has gone so far beyond making a film.
I just feel so personally connected to the story
and as an activist, I'm still involved in this
on a daily basis.
Hatice came to Sundance, right?
She came to Sundance, yeah.
She's still living in Istanbul?
She's in Istanbul, she got a place from Washington DC,
was starting her foundation to seek justice for Jamal,
and then COVID happened, and she went back to Istanbul
and she's been there since.
So, hopefully, on the other side of COVID,
she'll come back to Washington and resume work,
and hopefully, with the Biden administration,
there'll be a much warmer reception to the advocacy
and human rights work that she's seeking to do.
Where does the UN sit with all of this?
I mean, a big part of the narrative of the film
is kind of their own sort of investigation
into what occurred, and then Hatice's testimony
before the Council, but what is their power
to do anything and kind of where do they sit
with the whole affair?
Well, this was a another kind of "Icarus" analogy,
if I could make, is I had always viewed
that the World Anti-Doping Agency had authority,
and what I came to understand is that their job
is basically to just observe and report and be lame duck
and that they basically can't do anything.
They're just the security guard in the neighborhood
who drives around but is kind of feckless.
Exactly.
They're the guys like, go like,
"Okay, these guys are cheating, but yeah,
we have no power to punish them."
And so that was the amazing thing that I saw,
In "Icarus" in the story of Rodchenkov and this cheating,
is okay, you have this global regulator of world sport,
that also has no power to actually really do anything
and enact punishment, and that the power is actually
within the sporting federations themselves,
and within the Olympics, and this, that, the other,
and that WADA is really just the guy out there,
is like the watchdog pointing a finger,
but they're like a mall cop, right?
Well, I've found this same thing to be the case
with the UN.
So in the film, you see Agnes Callamard,
who is a special repertoire of United Nations.
She's a character.
An investigator, she's French, but she also teaches
at Columbia, and so, on the outset, you go,
okay, Agnes, is the UN, she's actually not,
she's a special repertoire to the United Nations,
meaning that she has been given permission
by the United Nations to launch an investigation,
her own independent investigation under the umbrella
of the United Nations Human Rights Committee.
But she doesn't actually work for the UN?
She's like a contractor?
It's complicated.
There's all these special repertoires of the UN
of their different committees that are able
to launch investigations that the UN will either provide
a budget for and then ultimately let them speak.
So Agnes does an entire investigation
of the Khashoggi murder, presents her finding
to the United Nations Human Rights Council,
but the Human Rights Council is kinda like WADA,
they're just there to observe and report,
they have no power, right?
And the United States under Trump actually
removed themselves from the UN Human Rights Committee.
If you can imagine it, the United States no longer
has a seat on the United Nations Human Rights Council.
How is that possible?
Trump pulled us out of the...
We're no longer part of the United Nations-
That's outrageous.
Human Rights Council
Unbelievable, but Saudi Arabia is.
(Bryan and Rich laugh)
So Agnes presents her finding to the Khashoggi murder,
as you see in the film, to the United Nations
Human Rights Committee, but, like WADA, the only thing
that they can do is really observe and report
and ultimately the UN, the General Assembly,
the Security Council have to take it up
to do something about it, and so the Human Rights Committee
doesn't have the power.
And ultimately, despite the evidence, despite the report,
despite the intelligence in the CIA
and British intelligence, and the transcript
and the audio and everything else,
the United Nations General Assembly, the Security Council,
has not taken up this investigation
and has not sanctioned Saudi Arabia, and has done nothing
to take action against Saudi Arabia, and not only that,
you saw the G20 just hosted, just weeks ago,
a week ago in Riyadh.
So when Hatice is testifying, that's not
in front of the General Assembly, that's in front
of the Human Rights Council, and you see
the Saudi contingent just basically get up and leave
in the middle of that, and there's no penalty for that,
or any kind of repercussions.
It was startling, and I think again, so we were allowed,
which is kind of unheard of, to have film cameras
within the United Nations, let alone
in an official United Nations
Human Rights Committee meeting.
But we were connected through Agnes, and we got in touch
with their communications office, and essentially,
they were like, "Okay, this is important,
we'll let you come film this."
And so we were granted a very special permission
to go in there with our cameras, to film Agnes' testimony,
and Hatice speaking in front
of the United Nations Human Rights Committee,
asking for justice for Jamal, and as she goes to speak,
the two Saudis that were there representing Saudi Arabia
on this matter, literally, get up and walked out the door.
So that did happen-
That did happen-
At that time 'cause when I was watching
I was like, I was wondering, I was like,
I wonder if Bryan edited this to make it look
like they got in the middle when actually they left
at the end?
No.
Wow.
That happened in real time.
It was unbelievable, literally, watching the Saudis
not only deny any responsibility,
say that this is a Saudi matter, but then Hatice
goes to give her two minutes, I can't remember,
three minutes of asking for justice, and as she goes
to speak, the two Saudi representatives
get up and walk out the door.
It's insane.
Insane.
Wow.
Was there anybody that you wish you could have interviewed
on camera that you just couldn't get to,
that would have made the story?
No.
And there was a question, I don't go to Saudi Arabia
for the film, and I don't-
I noticed that, have you ever been there?
No, and I don't interview any Saudi, MBS, or, whatever.
Did you ever reach out to any of those guys?
No, and the reason why is, much like "Icarus",
I had Grigory Rodchenkov.
Rodchenkov was a whistleblower, his evidence was solid.
The diaries, everything that he had brought forward
was solid, had been proven forensically,
proven to the McLaren Report, proven to the New York Times,
You know what I mean?
Right.
The evidence is, when you look at what he brought forward,
there's no denying, it is what it is,
and all the investigation surrounded, it proved it.
So in this case of the Khashoggi murder, right,
what was important to me was to get the evidence
from the Turkish, which I got, hear about the investigation
and why this is 100% to be believed,
and is an open and shut case, which is in the film,
to get all of that to basically present this story
in a way of the untold story behind this murder.
But to go and let's say interview
Mohammed bin Salman, right?
You already know what that interview is.
Did you do it?
No.
Did you know about it?
Who did it?
I don't know.
I mean, there was nothing to be gained by doing two things,
one, alerting Saudi Arabia that I was making the film,
two, trying to go to Saudi Arabia where,
you're risking your life, and three,
basically bringing propaganda and rhetoric into something.
I didn't wanna lend voice to that, because that's not true.
So, it to me, it was inconsequential to the narrative
of the film, just like, okay, let's say I would
have been able to interview Putin and ask him,
Well, I know what Putin has to say
about Grigory Rodchenkov and the allegations.
You can watch his conferences.
He's made multiple statements, he said that Grigory
is a member of US intelligence, that he's a spy,
that he is a traitor, that he is crazy,
that he belongs in a mental asylum.
I mean-
And you're not gonna catch him in a gotcha moment.
Right, right.
It's all well documented.
So, great.
So I go and interview Putin and what's he gonna tell me?
He's going to tell me, A, I didn't do it,
B, these are a bunch of lies, and C, Grigory is insane.
So I already know what what MBS is gonna say,
so what is the point of lending further credence
to a false narrative when it's really not what the story is?
Yeah, it's gonna be interesting to see
how everything plays out with MBs.
I mean, the arc being that he sort of originally
positioned himself as somewhat of a reformer
and is able to kind of covet global popular opinion,
then we kind of see that perhaps he's not that,
but he's sort of planting his flag with his vision 2030
and there's Davos in the desert thing that ends up
becoming kind of like a debacle, right?
So on some level, there's a backing up
of the global community who is reticent to be
too involved with this guy, and yet, there's so much money
involved and so much opportunity, those two things being
at odds with each other, like, how does that play out?
Is the money always win?
Well, the year the Davos in the desert is MBS's
annual, basically investment forum to bring together
world investment leaders, CEOs of major Fortune 500
and global companies to basically come and get investment
from Saudi Arabia or to put investment
into Saudi Arabia.
And two years ago, right after the Khashoggi murder,
many of these corporations, business leaders, governments,
whatever, didn't come to to Riyadh, they pulled out,
but they still sent like their third in charge,
fourth in charge, kind of, what's that word?
Culpable deniability or so.
We can't be seen here, but we actually still wanna
be in business with you.
The head of Goldman Sachs couldn't be there,
but his third in charge was there.
I see.
But this past year, they all came back.
Interesting.
So, the money's too big.
It's just it's too much to walk away from,
the investment is too big.
The cash is too much, and Saudi Arabia's future
essentially relies on no longer being dependent
on oil, right?
Right.
So in that regard, MBS is a great reformer,
meaning, okay, he is a young Prince.
He's 35 now, right?
34.
And he realizes that the future of his country
is basically not as being the world's oil supplier,
as Tesla and electric cars and all this stuff
is gaining and gaining and gaining and companies like Neo
in China, is the Tesla rival, I mean, their stock is up,
I don't know, 10,000% this year, right?
So we see this future of energy unfolding,
and so, arguably, over the next 10, 20 years, 30, right,
the reliance on oil is gonna become less and less and less.
So the only way that Saudi Arabia can survive
is to take all of these trillions of dollars, right?
Yeah, this massive liquidity and invest it globally.
And put it to use globally, either to bring investment
into the Kingdom or to invest outside of the Kingdom,
so that they have major stakes in this company,
or own whatever it is, hundreds of millions of shares
of Uber or, all these different investments
that they've made to either return investment
to the Kingdom, because they're not gonna get that
from oil any more or to bring investment into the Kingdom
because it can grow and also to educate the Saudi people
to basically be computer programmers, to build,
to construct, to basically do what we've been doing here
in the United States and other economies.
Or what you see in the UAE.
Right.
And Saudi Arabia and the UAE are best friends,
and MBZ, in many cases considered MBS is like Godfather,
that MBS takes his direction from MBZ in the Emirates.
So clearly, MBS is right on the that,
and that's part of Vision 2030,
is how to basically diversify the Kingdom.
One of the things he did was he brought Saudi Aramco public,
which there was a lot of controversy over that,
because a lot of people didn't think that the state's
oil company should be brought public,
but I mean, they only sold like 5% of it,
but in so doing overnight, they created, I think,
it's the second most valuable company in the world.
Apple, I think, has surpassed it now, but Saudi Aramco
is worth like 1.7 trillion, or something like that,
but that was the ability, again, for others to invest
in Saudi Arabia.
You look at these, the oil war that they created
with Russia this past year, which has led
to this, basically, the lowest oil prices,
we've seen in the generation, was again,
basically how to infuse the Kingdom with cash,
and basically expedite their oil supply
to basically flood money.
It's just, these are all ways that MBS
is trying to diversify
the Kingdom and open it up to investment,
and in many ways, there's a lot of positive things
about this, and Jamal Khashoggi said that many of the things
that MBS was doing was positive.
At the same hand, you have Loujain al-Hathloul,
the female activists who basically advocated for women
to drive in Saudi Arabia on trial right now in Saudi Arabia.
And what is she on trial for?
She's on trial for basically, freedom of speech.
Even though now women are allowed to drive in Saudi Arabia,
because it was her idea and it was her basically
pushing this, she was arrested, and she sat in a prison
for the last two years, tortured,
and her trial is now going on
in Saudi Arabia for I don't remember what the exact charges
are, it's like crimes against the state that basically,
she has spoke against the Kingdom.
Wow.
So even though that's now legal today,
she's being tried for basically instigating what is now law.
Right.
It wasn't...
And so this is continued, so it's complicated.
I was thinking off subject for a second, but you talk
about this cyber threat and like Pegasus,
and access to governments or these companies
can have into our devices, and what's become clear to me,
which I think we're going to see in the next several months,
is that, not only is that technology here,
all of us on planet earth are about to have this
on our phones.
When you think about what's happening
with COVID and Coronavirus, right?
The only way out of this is a vaccine,
and arguably, the only way out of this
is that every single person on the planet
can prove that they've been vaccinated.
So how are we going to be able to prove
that we've been vaccinated?
You can already see this, there's gonna be an app
on our phones, and every single place where we go,
whether it's a restaurant, whether it's an airport,
whether it's shopping at Costco, whether it's Whole Foods,
whether it's walking into the door of the business, right?
You're gonna open up this app on your phone,
they're gonna scan it, it's gonna show your photo,
there's a Rich Roll, it's gonna show
the date he was vaccinated, it's gonna show
when he was vaccinated, it's gonna show
that he's COVID, negative, and then you're gonna be allowed
to enter the premises.
Well, who's gonna control this app?
Our government.
This is going to be a national, international database,
and I guarantee that as this vaccine rolls out,
within the next five, six months, or whenever this is,
the only way, every single person on the planet
and in the Western world, at least to begin with,
will have to make a decision.
Do we want to go to a concert?
Do we want to go fly on a plane?
Do we want to go to a restaurant?
Do we want to go to a store?
Do we want to go into the market?
And the choice will be yes or no.
Kinda much like what happened as Christianity
made its way through the world,
which was a gun or a knife to your head?
Do you accept Jesus Christ as your Lord and Savior?
Yes, you live, no, you die.
I mean, that was the spread of of Christianity
throughout the world, and this is going to be,
essentially, our new reality,
for better or for worse.
Tracking every single place that you go,
and that gets added to some database to kind of quote
the social dilemma, like we are the product
and the data mining that can transpire when there's an app
that basically logs every single place that you go,
how long you're there, when you when you enter
and when you depart.
What is nutty, is we're already dealing with this
and, okay, Google has a lot of data.
Facebook has a lot of data or credit cards, right?
You can go pull up the credit card statement
and you go, okay, Bryan went here, Bryan went there,
Bryan went to this restaurant, but we in our minds
don't go, oh, our government knows that.
The government knows that, whatever it is,
I stayed at Rock Ramada Inn
or I stayed at a Ritz Carlton, right?
We go, okay, our credit card company knows that,
but our government doesn't know that.
Well, starting basically, right now, our government
and the International governments around the world
are not only going to know everything about us,
they're going to know every place we walk into.
They're gonna know whether or not I shop at Gucci
or whether I shop at Costco.
They're gonna know if I ate dinner at Nobu,
or if I went to McDonald's.
They're going to know everything about us, where we go,
where we've been, where we travel, what airline we board,
because that is the only way when you actually think
about what's going to happen with this COVID vaccine,
that it can actually be, right, successful.
Meaning, okay, you're going to have to show
when you went to a place that you've been vaccinated,
and if you don't show you've been vaccinated,
you're not gonna be able to go to the store,
you're not gonna be able to get on the plane,
you're not gonna be able to go anywhere.
There's gotta an analog solution to that somehow, though.
I doubt it.
I mean, I think the analog solution is, oh, you don't have
a smartphone, so they're gonna give you
like a driver's license.
That'll have like a chip in it or something.
Right, but the driver's license is gonna be
the same thing, 'cause they're gonna scan
the driver's license, and it's gonna go
into the same database.
Right.
So I think, we've been dealing with this for years,
and I'm not a conspiracy theorist, and so I don't view this
as a conspiracy theory at all, and I don't view this
as a, oh, wow, but that Big Brother moment is truly upon us.
I mean, it is here, and it's not even the now,
I mean, the moment is upon us, when you look at what's going
to happen as the way that this vaccine rolls out,
and you just use common sense, you go, "Well, of course,
this is what's going to happen."
You're not gonna be able to enter a restaurant
unless you show you've been vaccinated.
Yeah, you're gonna have to establish it.
And this is a national international protocol,
meaning, okay, you arrive in Switzerland-
Crossing borders.
Boom, and this is gonna be global.
You go to a restaurant in Zurich, you're gonna scan the app,
you go to a restaurant in Italy, you're gonna go anywhere
in the world, right, you're gonna have to show
that you've been vaccinated, and so now, Bryan and Rich Roll
and every person on the planet, unless you're living
in a tribal village in Africa, right?
Everything we do, everywhere we go, everything we shop,
and you think about this, just in the case
of anything, what this is, or-
The counter argument is gonna be similar
to the arguments that you heard with Snowden
in that, "Oh, it's just metadata, we don't actually know
anything about what you did, specifically,
we're just getting ones and zeros about whether people
entering and leaving are healthy, right?
I mean, I'm sure that'll be the response.
Of course, unless they wanna know,
unless they go-
"Hey, we're at the FBI, we need to pull up Bryan, he's-
We think John Smith might be whatever,
running a fraudulent business.
And then boom at the end of the search,
instead of subpoenaing the credit card,
subpoenaing the bank, subpoenas and doing
that whole process of investigation.
Right.
This will just boom, and you go, "oh, wow,
this guy is staying at this place, he's on this airline,
he's there, he's there, dah, dah, dah, dah, clearly-
But he when he gets behind the microphone,
he says this instead.
Yeah.
We can use that.
It's frightening now.
I think what is a-
What are we gonna do?
It's Minority Report.
It's all this stuff that we've seen for years and years
in movies and science fiction, and "Blade Runner"
and "1984", which was, we latched on the "1984"
as the theme of "Icarus", 'cause not only
was that Grigory's famous favorite book,
but it's that whole idea that Big Brother's watching,
that you're never going to beat the system,
that ultimately, the system has the strength
and the government is who is in charge.
And, you see this in "The Dissident", or not only
in the murder of Jamal, but the aftermath of this,
that there's no punishment and that my film
doesn't get distributed by an a major streamer
and the government's, right?
It's all these themes, this Orwellian theme of "1984"
and now, we're seeing it in our lives,
and I think COVID, for better or for worse,
'cause we want to get back to our lives, is-
We're all gonna line up and sign up for it.
Is that Big Brother moment, it is upon us.
It is that true, true, true, Big Brother moment.
It's very dystopian note to end this whole thing on.
But one thing we ca do is, your movies always
have a call to action to like, how can somebody
who sees the film or listens to this and feels inspired
to get involved, where do you direct that attention?
Well, the Human Rights Foundation, everything...
The film was basically made through charitable donations.
A lot of the marketing and advertising, again,
is being supported through charitable donations.
And that's all coming from the Human Rights Foundation.
So, I think there's a couple ways to get involved.
One doesn't involve, any money, it's purely what we saw
with the Arab Spring, or what we see in great movements
or Black Lives Matter or Me Too,
or any one of these movements that take action,
is they start at an individual level,
and it grows and grows and grows and voices are heard,
and I think that in the case of this,
there's a way to have your voice heard,
which is, you send a letter to your Congressman,
to your Senator, you go on their websites,
and you send an email and you say,
"Hey, I want you to take action
against human rights abuses in Saudi Arabia,
there should be punishment
for the murder of Jamal Khashoggi.
There should be accountability.
I don't condone you, Emmanuel Macron,
or you Justin Trudeau," or you name the person, right,
"doing business with this country,
so long as they are beheading 800, 900 people a year
for doing nothing more than tweeting,
so long as women are sitting in jails because they advocated
for the right to drive or people are being imprisoned,
simply for voicing an opinion."
Right?
So there's that and that is a call to action.
The other of course, is looking
at the Human Rights Foundation and either getting involved
with them in a volunteer level, or getting involved
in a donation base, because the work that they're doing
through the Oslo Freedom Forum and if you do a deep dive,
I mean, it's countries all over the world,
that they are supporting dissidents, they are supporting
people who have otherwise been forced to leave their country
essentially for wanting free speech,
or family members of people who have been murdered
in these countries for fighting for freedom of press,
or freedom of speech or human rights.
So that's the other place to get involved.
And then, I think is as Biden takes office,
I believe that there's a potential real kind of re-imagining
of the US-Saudi relations, and there's yet another way
to get involved in that sort of advocacy.
And I think those are the ways to get involved
and to make an impact and hopefully, most powerfully
is to see the film, and to tell your friends
about this film, because that leads to change.
What happened with "Icarus" was the film being on Netflix,
and being seen, had a 10,000 times bigger impact,
than the New York Times, than CNN, and all of the stories
and everything before, because all of a sudden,
there was a global audience that could see this film,
and that pressure led the IOC, the Olympic Committee
to take action, and that has still survived to this day.
And I believe that this film, if seen by enough people,
can have the same effect on foreign policies
all over the world regarding Saudi Arabia,
and it's not so much about punishment for MBS,
it's not, oh, does Mohammed bin Salman wind up in a jail,
that's unrealistic, but can this film lead
to pressuring change that tens of thousands of people
that are falsely jailed in Saudi prisons are released
and allowed to have freedom of speech,
or are allowed to voice their opinions on Twitter
without fear of retribution?
I believe that that is possible.
If enlightenment comes and sometimes,
a leader can become enlightened
because he realizes that by oppressing opinions,
doesn't really lead to any good, that you can actually
be a kind leader, that you can be a good leader,
that even if you're a King, it doesn't mean that you need
to be a bad King, you can be a good King,
and that's kinda my hope with this film.
Right, and that was kind of Khashoggi's
whole thing early on, right?
That was his whole thing.
Yeah.
I mean, his last breath and everything was, like, I mean,
"Hey, I'm not calling for the French Revolution here."
He was not advocating to go round up the rulers
and behead them, he was advocating-
The smallest of changes.
That simply that the royal family opened up the system
to more of a parliamentary system, that he believed
and he said this over and over again,
that one man's opinion, the leadership of one person
and only one person, under any situation,
cannot be good, that the best leadership has to be,
yes, there's a leader like a President,
but that there are other voices that are heard.
And what he saw and saw in the Kingdom
is that there was no other voice other than MBS.
And what's outlined in the film also, is the round up
at the (indistinct) Carlton where he wrestle
the other Princes and businesses leaders
and shake some down for money.
What he's done since taking power as a Crown Prince
is basically lock up anybody who can oppose him,
that he goes, "Hey, this is not the best way to lead.
The best way to lead is through kindness,
through allowing other opinions
and listening to other opinions."
And ultimately, not in service to the global,
the sort of prosperity that he seeks, and the approval
of the global community upon which he is reliant upon,
if he wants to actualize his Vision 2030.
What's really strange is, the trip that he took
to the United States, which was just months
before the Khashoggi murder, I think, and I can be misquoted
here, I think it was like March of 2018,
and Khashoggi was murdered in October 2018.
I'm pretty sure it was March, thereabouts.
He comes to the United States, Mohammed bin Salman,
and he had hired all these companies like McKinsey,
and all these huge consulting firms
that he was paying hundreds of millions of dollars,
to basically promote him in Washington
and among business leaders, as the great reformer,
as this young Prince, this great, this guy is loved
and he is so cool and he's hip and even when he was
in the United States, he was wearing a suit, right?
And he wasn't wearing a headdress and he wasn't wearing
the traditional Saudi garments, right?
So it's like, okay, this is a enlightened Islam,
this is an enlightened leader, he's Western, right?
And that's how he presented himself
and he took these meetings with everybody from Obama,
to Jeff Bezos, to Bill Gates to, on and on and on
and on, Elon Musk, and he and they set up
and he went to Washington, and then he came to Los Angeles
and took over the entire Four Seasons,
and he shut the entire hotel down.
I mean, what an ego I mean, like, really?
You needed to take the entire hotel,
all whatever it is, 300 rooms?
Did he do the thing where they fly in on their own jet
and then have all their cars in the-
Oh, yeah.
I mean, when you've seen this guy when he travels.
Where they roll out with the Rolls Royces and everything?
(Rich laughs)
I mean, he's literally flying on his own Airbus.
And not only is he on like his own Airbus or whatever it is,
he's then got like, fighter jets, following him
on the Airbus.
You see that in the movie.
Right, refueling him as he flies, and then he lands
and there's an, whatever it is, there's the Airbus
and then he's like a 747, I mean,
it is the most crazy, over the top, insane,
you'd think our President or whatever, the Secret Service
or something travels, Air Force One, forget about it,
I mean, this is 1,000 times that.
I mean, this is insane, I mean-
But I remember when he came to the US, and there was
that sense that this great reformer is here
and things are gonna change.
But where I was going with this is that consultants
and security experts that I said, and so, apparently,
wherever he went, so he locked himself up
in this Four Seasons in Beverly Hills,
and then he did the same thing in Silicon Valley,
and he would not go meet with anybody.
So all the meetings were hosted on his turf, right,
and there were all these like silver brief cases
that were being pulled in, and one of the guys in the film,
the head cyber security guy who was running
White House cybersecurity and FBI cyber security,
is that there is a lot of beliefs and apparently,
investigations, that they believe
that they were essentially, using these meetings,
he was getting the numbers, phone numbers of people
like Jeff Bezos, right?
And then-
He could then deploy Pegasus on and he (indistinct).
Because because they they were hacking Bezos
months before the Khashoggi murder.
So you wonder, who else did he get?
Who else did he get?
So these meetings while they're for business,
he was also using it to basically hack the phones
of leaders all over the world.
Like, hey, let's stay in touch on WhatsApp.
Right, right, right, hey, whatever.
"Hey, Elon Musk, nice to meet you Elon Musk.
What's your number?
Hey, what's your number?"
Right?
(Bryan laughs)
Oh shit.
Yeah, you would think after the Bezos thing,
all those guys are looking at their phone,
getting somebody on their phone
to make sure they're locked down.
I certainly don't know that for a fact,
but it'd be a wise thing to do, I would say.
Well, if all you wanted to do is make documentaries
about subjects like this, you would be able to do that
for the rest of your life, I think.
Even the idea of doing one around the vaccine
or around Saudi investment
in the United States entertainment companies,
there's no end to these threads that you can pull
on the themes that obviously speak to you.
I think that what will be interesting for me
is this film has been really two full years of my life.
It was a year and a half to make it,
I'm still working on this every single day
two years into it, and so the stories
really take over my life.
I mean, 'cause "Icarus" was such a personal story,
and I'm still very involved.
They actually just passed in Congress and the Senate,
the RADA, the Rodchenkov Anti-Doping Act,
just passed last week through the Senate,
It's waiting for Trump's signature, which is-
That's gotta be incredibly gratifying.
Which is amazing, so Rodchenkov actually has a law
passed in him that the United States has passed
to basically try to manage global doping in sports,
because WADA is so ineffective, and basically criminalizing
this in the US courts, and there's all
these logistics around it, but basically,
it makes it that if an athlete comes the United States
and if there's others, but Rodchenkov Anti-Doping Act
just passed and Russia is still banned
from global sport, and so it's lived on,
and so I think, for me, it's really looking at stories
that I think that I can tell, that can possibly
have a global impact, that can have resonance behind it
and live on I'm hoping that "The Dissident"
and the story behind the murder of Jamal Khashoggi
will be that, and certainly in other subject matter
that I'm looking at, and I think that the hard thing
and the question kinda becomes, what is that future
in having material like this distributed,
because it is becoming more and more difficult.
And, this, for example, and we talked about this,
but had the Human Rights Foundation not come in
and supported it this film, it wouldn't have gotten made.
I had went to all sorts of people before Thor and I meet up,
and they were all scared to finance it, right?
And so, when you have this level of fear going on
that is perpetuating societies, the question
is what is that next story, and will that next story be able
to be just told honestly?
And that kind of leads into the whole,
whether it's the false narratives going on
around election fraud, or it's the false narratives
that get put out of Russia, or Saudi or anything else?
I think it's becoming harder and harder
to just have something just go, the truth is the truth,
is the truth.
And we used to go, you'd pick up a New York Times
and go, okay, it's the New York Times,
it's the truth, right?
And now, you even have 50% of the country going,
the New York Times is not the truth,
the New York Times is fake news.
And you go, okay, how does this come to a place
where this stops, where the news becomes the news again,
truth becomes truth, again, facts become facts again,
and I don't have those answers-
Yeah, I mean finding our way back to that
is very difficult, and the irony being, of course,
that we've never had greater immediate access
to more information, and yet, our level of trust
in that information has never been lower.
Meanwhile, there's this squelching of expression
that is making it more difficult for films
that are endeavoring to tell the truth or shed light
on a difficult truth, like your own film,
and how do we see our way forward from that?
It does feel like somebody should put together
a streaming platform that is just all about stories
like this that are difficult, and it's gotta be
about the truth and the message and not about how
it's gonna fair in the global marketplace,
or, how are we're gonna grow this streaming enterprise
across the world and garner the investment
from these problematic nation states?
That needs to be done I mean, there are philanthropists
in the world.
Laurene Powell Jobs funded Concordia, Davis Guggenheim's
company about a year ago.
I mean-
The Participant still exists, don't they?
Where are they in all this?
They're basically no longer doing political content,
and the problem with Participant is that these models
are financially based.
So Participant is finding that there's not whatever profit
to be had, and these models, so I've been told,
that they're shying away from all this.
So I think that what's gonna happen is, or the perfect world
is you have a philanthropist, whether it's someone
like a Laurene Jobs or it's Jack Dorsey
who is, I feel like how he's handled Twitter
and it's been pretty cool.
And he's certainly pretty enlightened.
He's a perfect candidate, I think he would
be super interested in this idea.
Right, Dorsey, or maybe an Elon Musk, or, even Bill Gates.
That goes, okay, you know what?
What am I gonna do with all this wealth?
What are you gonna do with it?
Once you're worth more than, whatever it is,
a couple 100 million dollars, what are you gonna
do with it?
If you got $10 billion.
You're making a billion, two billion dollars a year,
just on the interest on your billions.
I mean, you can't spend it.
I mean, even Bill Gates, where you say, okay,
his mandate is I'm giving away all my wealth,
it doesn't matter how much he gives away,
every year, his wealth increases and increases
and you're going like, wait, but I thought
you were giving it all away?
But at the same time, Microsoft just keeps doubling
and doubling and doubling and doubling,
the guy can't give away enough money fast enough.
I mean, so ultimately, I think you look
at one of these people or persons that go,
just as much as I wanna give away my wealth to help
fight poverty in Africa, or just as much
as I wanna give away my wealth,
to find research or vaccines or irrigation systems
or this, that and the other, or, I wanna give away my wealth
to see to it that there is a global platform
that is well funded, well financed, well endowed,
that you've got that app, just like Netflix
that you can go to, and that there isn't
so much of a financial model behind it,
as there is a philanthropic model behind it,
to see to it that stories like this get told.
And to have have consumers subscribe to it
for a couple bucks makes it economically viable.
Right, exactly.
I mean, if it's something where, the guy's gotta decide,
okay, do I pay my 1,499 for Netflix, or do I pay my 1,499,
for whatever it is, truth,?
Well, that becomes difficult.
But if it's a subscription, that is whatever 299
and you know that you're gonna go on there,
and you're gonna have all sorts of content
that otherwise big media companies that are only looking
at shareholder accountability, growth in the region,
subscriber numbers, risk assessment of all these other
things that make it impossible to do that kind of content,
and if you have something like that,
that can be very, very powerful.
All right, so all you billionaires out there listening,
give Bryan a call.
Exactly.
(laughs)
Right?
I've thought about this many times, and I do think
that this is or will be the future
of stories like "The Dissident", because I don't see
these global media companies changing.
I mean, even if you look at a company, like, let's say,
HBO a few years ago, well, now it's Warner Media and AT&T.
I mean, it's all interconnected.
Yeah, it's a giant conglomerate.
Right, so the so as these conglomerates take hold,
and the Amazons of the world,
everything becomes a risk assessment.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's interesting, because the streaming universe,
you do have to credit it with providing the opportunity
for a lot of independent stories to be told and shared
and celebrated in a way that would not have been possible
in the theatrical window model.
So it has done...
Not as many people would have seen "Icarus",
if it were not for Netflix, of course.
It's like it's unbelievable, the power of these platforms
to help smaller filmmakers and stories
that aren't gonna get greenlit, to be in the multiplex,
and yet at the same time, there is this risk analysis
that is having this squelching impact.
What you have is, like in the case of Netflix,
the Netflix that did "Icarus" three years ago,
is not the Netflix of today, it's a different company.
That was a company that had 100 million subscribers
versus 200 million subscribers.
That was a company that was very hungry at the at the time
to show that it could be an awards contender,
show that it could evolve beyond "House of Cards"
and it was it was a different company three years ago.
And what happens, for better for worse,
'cause I love Netflix, I mean the majority
of "The Queens Gambit" that I just finished watching
is extraordinary, it's extraordinary.
And there's so much extraordinary content on there,
and I am sure that I will continue to do content,
make content and have content on Netflix.
They're awesome, and they're amazing at what they do,
I love them.
But on the other hand, because of how big they are,
and the growth that they've had and where they're at
in the world right now, there is a whole other risk model
that comes into it, and in many ways,
you can't fault them either, because if you're running
that company, the burden that comes on top of that, to grow,
to have shareholder value, and to also not put your company
at risk, also becomes very, very hard.
And so I don't have that answer to it,
because at the same time I'm not angry at them,
I love them, I think they're amazing
and I love what they're doing and I love the content
and the forum that they've provided for so many people
and what they did for "Icarus"
was outstanding and astounding.
At the same time, there's a conundrum where something
gets so big, that risk assessment will always get in the way
or become a variable as to whether you do something or not.
Yeah.
We gotta end this thing.
Everybody, please go see this movie.
It was a very impactful for me.
I've seen it twice.
I was moved by it, it made me think.
It's a heavy film, but it also, like we said at the outset,
definitely a thriller.
You're on this rollercoaster ride as the story unfolds,
and you did this with a masterstroke, it's extraordinary.
So congratulations on the movie, it opens December 25th
in limited theaters and then January 8th,
on your VOD platform.
Exactly, it'll be available on-demand, to rent
on basically all platforms beginning January 8th.
Yeah, check it out.
And in theaters December 25th
if you have a theater open near you.
Right.
You can learn more about it at thedissident.com
and you can find Bryan pretty easily on the Internet
at Bryan Fogel, right?
Yeah, at Bryan Fogel on Twitter, Instagram, I keep private
but if you add me I'll make sure you're not a Saudi trolling
and then accept.
You might know, you know what I mean?
You should know better than anyone.
It's funny, yeah, I mean, I keep my accounts private
'cause I don't have time for it, but then I'll click
and I go, wait, this looks like a honeypot or something.
And it's like something-
Everything that comes in, you must think,
"Do I really wanna click on this?
I'm like, this doesn't look like a real person.
(Bryan and Rich laugh)
Or something clicks in and I'm like,
yeah, something right here.
(Rich sighs)
What are we gonna do?
Go ride our bikes.
Yeah, let's go ride bikes,
how about that?
Go ski, go ride bikes.
Yes, cool.
'Cause that's what we should do for sure.
Thank you, man, that was super powerful.
So much respect for putting yourself out there
in a really powerful way to forge positive change.
It's an example for me and how I think
about how I interface with the world,
and I know for so many people out there,
so I appreciate you my friend.
Thanks, Rich.
It's good to be back on and talking to you again.
Cool.
You're amazing and if any of you haven't seen
Rich's new book, you have to get it.
It's incredible, it's on my coffee table.
Yeah, 'cause you're in it.
I am in it.
Cool, thank you.
Peace.